Damit ich nicht ganz so...
Du musst erst mal ein File-Actron-Hips zumachen.
Mir ist noch mal unterlaufen,
Kian, ich habe vergessen, die
Marte-Rechzeitigkeit zu stellen.
Wir hören uns immer noch doppelt.
Oder ich höre dich doppelt.
Ich höre dich, also ich höre mich selber und dich auch.
So, jetzt.
Warum hast du einen ganzen Stapel
Papier-3D-Brillen?
Weil es die nicht einzeln zu kaufen gibt.
Ich wollte mal
als Hackweek-Projekt, ich hatte irgendwie
festgestellt, ich habe auf Arbeit, wir machen ja so
Zeugs mit Webcams. Und ich hatte
zwei Webcams auf meinem Bildschirm oben
drauf und da habe ich überlegt,
ich könnte auch einfach irgendwie 3D machen.
Okay, das klingt schön.
Da bin ich ja auch noch nicht dazu gekommen, aber ich habe mir schon mal diese Brillen bestellt.
Das klingt schon super.
Das wäre noch so ein Rust WebAssembly-Projekt.
Das muss ich mal noch machen,
aber ich habe noch nicht gut beschrieben bekommen.
Eigentlich ist es, glaube ich, bloß Überblenden.
Ganz billiges mit einem...
Du musst ja irgendwie den roten und blauen Channel shiften
und dann...
Naja, du musst den einen Channel,
du musst das glaube ich, das eine auf schwarz-weiß
tun und das andere,
du musst beide auf schwarz-weiß tun und dann das eine
einfach züren und das andere und dann
gar nicht, das ist schwarz-weiß.
Das 3D ist generell schwarz-weiß.
Ne, das ist einfacher in schwarz-weiß.
Du kannst es auch irgendwie,
also da wird es dann spannender, weil du musst
dann irgendwie so machen, dass das Züren und das
Rot dann glaube ich wieder einen normalen Farbton
ergibt, das heißt du musst es irgendwie ein bisschen,
aber da wird es mir dann, also wie gesagt,
ich habe leider noch nichts gutes,
ich habe nicht wirklich die Zeit gehabt,
wirklich nachzugucken, wie der Algorithmus funktioniert.
Okay, da muss ich mal ein bisschen einlesen, aber es ist
wahrscheinlich...
Skade ist Typing.
Hi Florian!
Hi!
Okay, Jan, ich lasse dich wieder über Signal ranten.
Ich habe nicht mehr so viel Beef mit Signal.
Das ist alles dasselbe Beef, der ändert sich ja nicht so.
Warum?
Die haben extra für dich eine Kryptowährung eingeführt.
Ja, super.
Hey Kilian!
Hey Flo!
Hey Henrik!
Willkommen zur Akronomisierbar-Folge
Oh mein Gott!
50!
Wir haben es geschafft, nach 5 Jahren 50 Folgen
Das ist jetzt wirklich
Bei unserem wöchentlichen Podcast, den wir machen
ist das super, dass wir nach 5 Jahren
endlich die 50 geschafft haben, glaube ich
Folge 52. Und angekündigt
in der Jubiläumsfolge?
Tatsächlich ist es eine Jubiläumsfolge.
Ja, dementsprechend haben wir uns,
wie wir das auch die letzten zwei Male gemacht haben,
eigentlich schon wieder einen Gast eingeladen, weil wir das so gerne machen.
Und zwar Florian Gilcher. Schön, dass wir
dich wieder zu Besuch haben bei uns.
Hi. Florian, schon mal
mehrmals in dieser Folge
gewesen. Schon mal trifft es nicht gut.
Du bist Wiederholungstäter.
Ja, das ist jetzt zum dritten Mal.
Genau, und das ist jetzt quasi unsere
Folge zum Thema
chatten. Aber zum dritten Mal heißt das,
du bist auf der Gäste-Highscore ganz oben
mittlerweile, oder? Ja, so irgendwo
zwischen Jupp und Steiger,
würde ich sagen.
Ja.
Man muss halt mal aufholen, ne?
Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Übrigens letztens erzählt bekommen,
dass man unseren Podcast prima zum Einschlafen
hören kann. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das gut oder schlecht
ist. Also
hallo an Personen da draußen, die
die gerade einnickt, finde ich witzig.
Ich würde das unverschämt von dir.
Aber schlaf ruhig weiter.
Ich höre ja Podcasts zum Einschlafen,
aber nicht euren.
Das wäre dich ein bisschen zu anstrengend.
Unsere Laber-Scheiß jetzt.
Also unseres ist vor allem zu unstrukturiert
zum Einschlafen, muss ich sagen.
Was ich super zum Einschlafen nehme,
sind die Sterngeschichten von Florian Freistetter.
Weil das ist ein Astro-Thema.
Das ist für mich erstens super entspannt.
Zweitens ist es geschrieben,
es ist niedergeschrieben und abgelesen,
was irgendwie den Duktus sehr entspannt
macht. Sprachduktus.
Der hat aber wirklich einen
sehr schönen Duktus.
Und ich muss
sagen, da stört es mich, dass es dann
nicht genug Folgen gibt. Der hat
schon 400 Folgen gemacht,
aber ich bräuchte ja quasi
jede Woche eine. Ich kann so eine 15-Minuten-Folge
eine Woche lang hören, weil ich irgendwie
immer nach 5 Minuten weg bin. Das funktioniert super.
Florian, was hörst du zum Einschlafen?
Alles durch die Bank, ich brauche immer nur so zwei Minuten zum Einschlafen, weil wenn Leute reden, während ich im Bett liege, schlafe ich sofort ein.
Und Podcasts streiten sich mit einem danach nicht darüber.
Das stimmt.
Das ist so ein schöner Punkt.
Oh Mann.
Was immer gerade als Folge drin liegt, 20-Minuten-Timer, um dann danach festzustellen, dass wir nur zwei Minuten von den 20 Minuten festbekommen.
Und deswegen wird es diese Timer ja auch geben in den ganzen Apps, weil das wahrscheinlich so viele Leute machen,
wenn man sich da den 5-Minuten-Podcast-Timer einstellen kann und dann der Podcast ausgeht.
Dabei ist man wahrscheinlich gar nicht nach zwei Minuten eingeschlafen, weil man vergisst einfach die letzten zehn Minuten.
Kein Mensch kann sich bewusst daran erinnern, wie er einschläft. Man wacht einfach plötzlich wieder auf.
Ich glaube, es werden einfach die letzten 10 Minuten von dem, was du im Bett machst, einfach nicht gespeichert oder so.
Groseligerweise.
Ich glaube, ein Schlafforscher könnte uns da mehr zu erzählen.
Wir sollten uns mal einen Schlafforscher einladen.
Aber das ist, glaube ich, auch der Grund, oder das stört mich dann bei Audible im Hörbuch zum Einschlafen.
Da finde ich es erstens schlimmer, was zu verpassen.
Ja, das geht nicht.
Zum anderen hat die App überhaupt keine gute Einschlaffunktion.
Weil wenn du dann einmal über so ein arbiträr gewähltes Chapter hinaus springst,
kannst du nicht wieder genauso gut zurückspringen.
Ja, vielleicht genau deswegen, weil es halt einfach auch nicht gut funktioniert.
Vielleicht gibt es Menschen, die das gut können.
Vielleicht gibt es sicherlich auch Hörbücher, mit denen man prima einschlafen kann.
Aber sowas Spannendes, das...
Ich kann zum Beispiel das Hörbuch von Florian Freistädter sehr gut im Bild.
Das ist quasi nochmal Bonus-Sternengeschichten plus,
ohne diese Intro-Melodie.
Gibt es ein Buch von ihm, selber eingesprochen?
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
kostenlose Startup-Idee.
Das Ganze mit einem Schlaftracker verbinden.
Damit man
Podcast-App plus Schlaftracker?
Ja.
Damit man weiß, wann man in die entsprechenden
Schlafphasen eingetreten ist und dann wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr. Und das kannst du dann als
Analytics direkt an die Podcast-Produzenten
verkaufen, so was die sehr langweiligen
Phasen sind, wo die meisten Leute einnicken.
Damit sie die Werbung vor die Einschlafphase
packen können.
Oder die Werbung in die Tiefschlafphase, um direkt
dein Unterbewusstsein anzusprechen.
Er ist eingeschlafen.
Jetzt können wir die subliminale
Werbung schalten.
Ivan et Niosch.
Du möchtest Coca-Cola trinken.
Oh mein Gott.
Hatten wir es da nicht
das letzte Mal von?
Thema sind ja diesmal auch wieder Chats.
Da hatten wir es doch von Discord
und Systemd.
Und die Daten, was für Spiele man verkauft.
Ach was?
Was für Spiele man spielt, verkaufen.
Ach, wirklich?
Deswegen haben die ja dieses Tracking-Feature,
was man gerade spielt.
Ich meine, klar, man kann
das natürlich als Social-Feature verkaufen, aber
mit den Daten noch mehr anfangen,
da freut sich natürlich
die Market...
Wie nennt man die Menschen,
die Geld
schaffeln in der Firma?
Das Management?
Okay, alle.
Die Sales? Ja, die Sales, Leute.
Normalerweise
immer die Verkäuferin.
Also ich habe ja viel in der Logistik gearbeitet.
Ich habe mal bei einer Firma gearbeitet,
die war da ganz strikt. Die einzigen, die bei uns so
richtig Wert schöpfen, sind die Leute, die im Laden
verkaufen. Ist an sich nicht so
verkehrt.
War nicht eine gute Firmenausrichtung.
Ich habe bei mir in Discord immer
Custom-Spiele drin und spiele
meistens den ganzen Tag Xcode
beziehungsweise manchmal
abends noch Folding at Home.
Das ist ein super Spiel, das spiele die Leute
stundenlang. Wahnsinn.
Das ist ja engaging.
Folding at Home ist eigentlich die Optimierung
des Idle-Trackers.
Du musst gar nicht mehr machen.
Folding at Home, das originale
Idle-RPG.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, apropos Chat, wollen wir denn mal
eine Runde Idle-RPG spielen?
Das erinnert mich an die guten alten Zeiten
im FSR damals, wo der FSR
IRC-Surfer noch lief, wo wir alle
im Idle-RPG richtig aktiv,
also aktiv in Anführungsstrichen waren.
und dann irgendwer noch so ein Map-Plugin installiert hat,
wo du im Idle-RPG auch noch quasi Bewegungen mit drin hattest,
welche Charaktere sich wohin bewegt haben auf der Karte.
Könnt ihr mich mal abholen, was zum geilen Idle-RPG ist?
Idle-RPG ist so ein herrliches RPG, was sich in Chaträumen spielt,
durch einen Chatbot, der mit anwesend ist.
Und der Witz an der Sache ist, du spielst es, indem du nichts tust.
Also du wirst aktiv dafür beschraft, wenn du in dem Raum aktiv bist,
aber wenn du rumidilst und nichts machst,
dann gewinnst du Kämpfe gegen Monster
und gewinnst 6B-Erfahrung
und Level dazu. Wenn du so der Noob bist,
der schreibt, hi, ich bin neu hier und
dann wirst du erstmal getötet oder was? Quasi.
Oh man. Also
es ist schlicht und einfach so, stell dir Diablo
vor, noch weiter optimiert, indem man es
gar nicht mehr bedienen muss und die Zahlen einfach von
selbst hochlaufen.
Das ist quasi, ja gut, das kenne ich
aber als Let's Plays quasi.
Das spiele ich.
Ich muss nichts bezahlen, ich gehe einfach
auf YouTube, ich gebe Diablo ein und
spielt es sich von alleine vor meinen Augen.
Ob es ein RPG Let's Plays gibt,
das ist doch mal eine Nische.
Ich würde sowas als Screensaver
nehmen, ganz ehrlich. Ich vermisse an manchen
Stellen so Screensaver. Ich habe neulich
irgendwie eine Stunde, eine dreiviertelstundige
Doku über diesen komischen
Johnny Castaway Screensaver geguckt.
Kennt ihr den, wo so ein Typ
einfach auf so einer Insel sitzt und da ist eine
richtig komplexe Geschichte in so einem Screensaver
drin, der für
wuppige 15 Megabyte groß war. Du meinst doch,
da wird irgendwie noch erstaunlich viel erzählt
viel Abwechslung. Da gibt es so Random-Animationen,
wo der irgendwie hinter seiner Palme langläuft
und dann auf der anderen Seite mit einer Angel rauskommt oder sowas.
Aber da gibt es irgendwie noch eine Sub-Story, die sich
über eine Woche oder zwei Wochen
erzählt. Das war mir gar nicht klar.
Aber, Henry, Kau-Clicker kennst du, oder?
Bitte was?
Nein. Kau-Clicker?
Kau-Clicker? Nein, kenn ich nicht.
Oh, okay.
Kau-Clicker war eine App auf Facebook, als es noch
diese ganzen Mafia-Wars und so weiter
Dinger gab, wo du einfach eine Kuh hattest und du musstest
jeden Tag draufklicken.
Du durfst es irgendwie alle vier, fünf Stunden auf die Kuh klicken und du konntest dir für einen Dollar oder so bis zu fünf weitere Kühe kaufen.
Das klingt, als müsste man das mit Pappetiergut spielen.
Genau, dann musstest du einfach mehr klicken und wer die meisten Klicks hat, hat gewonnen und so weiter und so fort.
Das war eher mehr ein soziales Experiment und der hat das irgendwann eingestellt und dann haben die Leute sich beschwert, wie er dann ihre Kühe und ihre Klicks wegnehmen kann und so weiter und so fort.
Also man kann diese ganzen Sachen sehr, sehr runterbrechen.
Das ist so eine Art Tamar Goji, ne?
Das ist ja genau das.
Ja, aber du musst dich noch nicht mal damit beschäftigen.
Also ja, in dem Fall schon, du musst halt schon klicken, aber genau.
Sobald die Leute eine Minimalinteraktion haben, haben sie einen Bezug dazu.
Ja, du bist dann irgendwo investet, du hast da ja schon so viele gefühlt Monate deines Lebens reingesteckt.
Genau, und dann hast du das halt ein Wert da.
Kannst du nicht aufhören damit.
Ich habe bestimmt 2000 Mal auf diese Google geklickt.
Ich dachte, du meintest sowas wie
diese geilen... Cookie-Clicker.
Nicht Cookie-Clicker,
diese
Paperclip-Maschinen-Geschichten.
Ja, das stimmt genauso.
Aber da ist richtig, da passiert ja wenigstens
was. Da ist zwar nicht viel
Optik drin, aber
Florian, kennst du diese
Paperclip-Spiele, wo du irgendwie so eine Paperclip-Wirtschaft
und irgendwie irgendwann
produzierst du 35 Milliarden
Paperclips pro Sekunde oder sowas?
Am Anfang kriegst du noch mit jedem Klick
eins explizit und für die ersten zehn kannst du dir was kaufen
und dann langsam deine Firma upgraden oder so.
Ja, bis du am Ende
dann das Universum in Paperclips gemacht hast.
Paperclips-Fabrikas.
Ich möchte weder bestätigen
noch nicht bestätigen, dass ich es durchgespielt habe.
Ich habe erstaunlich viel Zeit mit diesem Spiel auf Arbeit
verbracht, muss ich sagen. Immer wenn du so wartest,
dass gerade irgendein Bild läuft
oder sowas und das hat leider so süchtig
gemacht, dass ich auch vielleicht mal eine Stunde oder zwei
einfach nur dieses Spiel gespielt habe.
Naja, wenn CI langsam läuft, ne?
Jaja, Jenkins ist schuld, ich nicht.
Das ist wie dieses Dino-Spiel in Chrome,
was bei Ladefehler kommt.
Also wo man einfach mal was zu tun sucht.
Das kannst du einfach spielen auf chromedino.com,
ohne dass du Chrome installiert haben musst,
dann rennt der plötzlich los, das ist sehr schön.
Da gibt es sogar einen Highscore.
Und es gibt einen Super Mario-Them.
Okay, ich spiele schon gleich.
Wir hatten ein Thema.
und zwar
in welcher Folge hatten wir denn das letzte Mal
über Chats geredet?
Ich füge das mal nach, es gibt einen Link in den
Shownotes.
In der Rant-Bubble-Folge
August 2018
Oh mein Gott. Du bist ja informiert.
Oh mein Gott.
Naja, es war ganz einfach, das war noch die Trainingsvorbereitung
für die letzte Bogen-Schießfüfung
vor der Pandemie
in Dresden
und ich habe
die Folge
fort. Genau, ich habe die Folge
kurz vorher nochmal angehört, da hatte ich noch leicht
angedeutet, dass ich gerade so eine neue Firma in der
Gründung hätte. Also,
wenn ihr noch nicht up-to-date seid
und das ist ja schließlich drei Jahre her, dann hört
euch Folge, welche Folge?
Run Bubble, ich glaube, das ist
Folge Nummer 20
oder so. Genau, hört euch die nochmal
an und dann
sehen wir uns in wenigen Sekunden wieder.
Okay,
ihr habt die Folge jetzt offenbar durchgehört.
Schön, ihr seid besser informiert als ich.
momentan. Florian ist up to date
und wir haben über Chats geredet das letzte Mal.
So, und irgendwie ist ja bei Chats
in den letzten drei Jahren, ist da viel passiert,
ehrlich gesagt. Also es gab so ein paar
Katastrophen, aber so richtig
was essentiell krass
Neues ist in den letzten drei Jahren nicht
passiert, oder? Ja, wenn du schon die letzten drei Jahre ansprichst,
dann kamen halt schon ein paar Sachen dazu.
Wie sieht denn so die Landschaft momentan aus?
Also wir haben immer noch irgendwie
fünf verschiedene Messenger auf unseren Telefonen,
um irgendwie mit allen Leuten zu reden. Nur fünf?
Nur fünf? Warte mal,
Ich habe hier iMessage,
wie viele finden Sie direkt auf der Startseite?
Signal
und dann versuche ich mich eigentlich zu begrenzen.
Ich habe noch E-Mail und Twitter.
Zählt das?
Ich habe explizit kein Telegram auf meinem Telefon.
Ich habe Slack. Verdammt, ich habe noch Slack.
Wie schaut es bei euch aus?
Ja, auf 7 komme ich auch.
Bei mir ist Telegram dabei.
Also ich habe Streamer, Signal, Messages
zähle ich jetzt mal nicht dazu.
Telegram.
Ja, schon.
ISC Cloud, Skype, Discord,
WhatsApp und so.
Also schon einiges.
Nischenprodukte hier.
Ist CCloud dieses C-File?
Nein, ISC Cloud.
Ach, ISC Cloud.
ISC Cloud habe ich auch lange genutzt.
Das ist zwar
in manchen Kreisen arg verrufen,
aber es war doch sehr bequem.
Die hatten recht gute Clients
für Mobile auch mit damals und
IRC auf Mobile nutzen, war halt so oder so
immer schon scheiße.
Und damit ging das recht bequem tatsächlich.
Auch mit Notifications und so.
Richtig gut eigentlich.
Sind die einzigen, die legal ein
alternatives Slack-Interface
anbieten dürfen?
Aber die
Slack-IRC-Bridge gibt es doch auch nicht mehr, oder?
Also die offizielle IRC-Gateway, den
Slack anfangs hatte. Genau.
Und genau da ist IRC-Cloud dann reingelaufen
und hat gesagt, aber unser Interface könnte,
wir haben da einen Deal mit Slack.
Ach so, die haben, oh krass.
Witzig. Ah, ich glaube, die App
habe ich sogar schon bei Leuten gesehen, genau.
Also sah bei denen das Slack so komisch aus.
Okay, ich fange mal vorne an.
Es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Messengern,
die so existieren, die wir nutzen.
Ihr Hörer wisst ja wahrscheinlich auch,
dass ihr nicht nur die eine App nutzt mit Freundin und Familie,
Entschuldigung, ihr Hörerin.
Und alle sind kaputt.
Alle sind kaputt irgendwo, genau.
Das haben wir auch schon in relativ frühen Folgen
dieses Podcast festgestellt.
Ich möchte auch mal gerade erwähnen,
dass keiner von uns Conversations
oder irgendeinen anderen XMPP-Client aufgezählt hat.
Ja, weil Conversations gibt es nur für Android.
Conversations ist der einzig gute XMPP-Client,
meiner Meinung nach.
Das habe ich auch schon öfter in diesem Podcast angemerkt.
Und deswegen ist Jabba halt für mich auch so ein bisschen tot,
weil es genau einen guten Client gibt.
Du deckst es nur auf Android.
Genau.
Und jetzt auf Windows, auf Windows 11.
But be direct, Grass,
Du hattest gerade so einen schönen Laufkirchen,
wo ich leider reingekritscht bin.
Nee, Flo, du meinst ja gerade alles ist irgendwo kaputt.
Genau das ist halt das Problem.
Man hat Gripes mit allem aus verschiedenen Gründen.
Und ja, deswegen ist man so ein bisschen daran gebunden,
in verschiedenen Kreisen verschiedene Clients zu nutzen.
Viele von euch kennen vermutlich diesen einen wunderschönen XKCD.
Den können wir auch mal wieder in die Shownotes packen.
Von den Messaging-Bubbles, die man so mit verschiedenen Kontakten hat,
wo alles Mögliche aufgezählt ist,
bis hin zu Unix Wall und Bathroom Wall und Apache Request Log.
Was übrigens auch erstaunlich gut funktioniert.
Also ich habe mit zwei Freunden zusammen, hatten wir mal ein Python-Script gebastelt,
was einfach nur über Apache Request Log wirklich so ein bisschen Chat aufzieht.
Über die gegenseitigen Server.
Das hat recht gut funktioniert.
Ja, genau. Aber alles ist irgendwo broken und deswegen nutzen wir verschiedene Dinge.
Warum ist denn alles broken?
Was stört uns denn an Sachen?
Ach, die Technik muss ich sagen,
also tut inzwischen halbwegs.
Nachrichten kommen an.
Das Problem ist ja eigentlich,
dass die technisch häufig eigentlich okay sind,
aber entweder sind sie World Gardens
oder sie sind halt UX-mäßig kaputt
oder du musst irgendwie Clients aus den 90ern verwenden.
Oder es gibt nur einen Client.
Ja gut, das hatten wir das letzte Mal schon
da ist ja
XMPP gegengelaufen
tolles Protokoll, aber wie verwende ich es
und
ja
ich meine
wir können einfach mal durchgehen, was es gibt und was sich
eigentlich verändert hat, es hat sich nicht in den letzten drei Jahren schon
einiges geändert, aber
wir haben ja hier so ein bisschen so ein Roster, um in der
Terminologie mal zu bleiben, also
es gibt
Threema noch, offenbar.
Noch.
Von denen habe ich auch schon ewig nichts mehr gehört,
ehrlich gesagt. Die hatten damals unglaublich
gutes Timing bewiesen, als
WhatsApp von Facebook gekauft wurde, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Da war plötzlich Threema da. Die waren kurz davor da
und also wirklich literally so
gefühlt, also sicherlich schon ein paar Monate
früher, aber da waren sie, meiner Meinung nach, zumindest recht
unbekannt, in meiner Bubble sind sie aufgetaucht und plötzlich
kam so dieser WhatsApp-Deal und
da sind natürlich ziemlich viele Leute
von WhatsApp abgesprungen, haben sich Alternativen gesucht und
Thilma hat groß gesagt, wir sind in der Schweiz
Incorporated und
wir sind verschlüsselt und sicher und das war
natürlich ein riesen Boost für die, würde ich behaupten.
Also ich würde da gerne mal Stats von
denen sehen, wie das damals aussah.
Ja und sie hatten noch zwei Vorteile
für mich. Du musstest Geld für die App
bezahlen, einmal und das war's. Es gab
keinen Werbedeal oder Datendeal oder sowas.
Du wusstest, ich bin der Kunde
und du hattest, was
ich schön fand gegenüber Signal war,
du hattest diese Telefonnummerbindung nicht
Du hast einen Account mit irgendeinem Hashcode gehabt und das war dann dein Kürzel und das konntest du dann auch woanders verwenden. Die anderen mussten deine Telefonnummer nicht unbedingt kennen.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, by the way, dass ich für WhatsApp damals einen Euro gezahlt habe oder so.
Das ist ein sehr schlechtes Timing bewiesen.
Das ist ja Ewigkeiten her.
Swimmer hat vor allem eigentlich einen ziemlich guten Client, muss ich ehrlich sagen. Also Mobile Client.
Der Webclient ist, naja, also der verliert halt mal Nachrichten.
Damit sind wir wieder bei dem Chat, der Nachrichten verliert.
Ja, manchmal wird die Verbindung zum Device nicht ordentlich, also es braucht unbedingt das Telefon und das Telefon muss an sein.
Die machen das wie WhatsApp, die forwarden das zu deinem Gerät und sprechen nur über das Gerät mit dem eigentlichen Server.
Genau, und dann verlieren sie hin und wieder mal eine Nachricht.
Das Thema kostet momentan vier Euro.
Ja, aber ansonsten, so wenn man es nur als der Mobilclient, wie gesagt, das Native funktioniert extrem gut.
Ja, hat keine Kryptowährung, womit wir bei Signal wären.
Nein, da kommen wir gleich zu.
Aber ja, du hast recht, der Client fühlt sich tatsächlich richtig sauber an.
Es ist eine angenehm zu bedienende native App.
Und die hatten auch, also das ist mittlerweile ja der Standard und ich wette auch, die haben das nicht erfunden.
Aber bei Threema fand ich es mit, aber ich glaube, das erste Mal gesehen gehabt, dass man sich gegenseitig QR-Code oder irgendwelche Codes gescannt hat, um sich zu verifizieren, was halt auch sehr angenehm flink funktioniert hatte. Und das lief gut. Man konnte sich sicher sein, dass man mit dem Gegenüber nur noch spricht.
Und ja,
ich habe es nie verifiziert oder so,
aber es fühlte sich auch nach gut funktionierender
Verschlüsselung an.
Aber sie waren ja schon relativ Anfang,
hatten sie, glaube ich, auch
Audits mit publiziert, dass das auch alles
seine Richtigkeit hatte. Sie waren
lange, lange, lange, lange Jahre nicht
Open Source. Das haben sie ja jetzt langsam
nachgezogen, aber ich glaube fast nur
die Clients oder so,
nicht die Infra, wenn ich das richtig
im Kopf habe. Genau.
Genau.
Ansonsten habe ich gerade dadurch, dass
die Clients Open Source geworden sind,
ich folge ja schon lange einem
GitHub-Repo, wo Leute
einfach nur Interesse daran haben, Dinge zu Matrix
zu bridgen und als die Threema-Clients
Open Source geworden sind, was dann hier ist,
sind ja hier, die Kommunikation ist
geklärt, wer baut die Threema-Bridge.
Aber ich glaube nicht,
dass da viel passiert ist, weil das halt alles noch so ein bisschen
in der Schwebe hing.
Mit wie vielen Leuten, Florian, benutzen du
Threema? Weil ich sehe gerade, der Client kostet
4 Euro und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das
einfach abschreckt?
Sechs oder sieben verschiedenen
persönlich, aber Großteils
Familienmitglieder. Meine Familie
verwendet wie immer kein WhatsApp.
Zumindest der eine Teil.
Es ist immer
dieser familiäre Gruppenzwang.
Bei mir ist es exakt
das Problem, dass ich im Familienkreis,
mein Opa hat die Gruppe vor Jahren
mal aufgemacht, eine WhatsApp-Gruppe habe, von der
ich noch nicht loskomme.
Und ich so gerne ich es versuchen wollte,
die Menschen wegzubewegen
von der Plattform.
Da sind natürlich relativ viele Menschen drin, also
das ist ein größerer Familienkreis
und ich habe
verschiedene Betriebssysteme und Plattformen
gezogen und, naja,
verschiedene Betriebssysteme, also explizit
Android und iOS. Du musst da einfach mal jedem eine Runde Threema
spendieren. Ja, aber ich weiß auch nicht, ob Threema die
Plattform ist, wo ich dann hin möchte, weil dann habe ich wieder keine,
bei WhatsApp kann ich zumindest das Ding wegbridgen und
nutzen, aber da kommen wir auch
noch zu. Okay, also Threema
gibt es noch. Dann gab es noch eine andere Firma
in der Schweiz, die irgendwie ganz interessant
klang, aber von der ich schon eine Weile nicht mehr gehört habe.
Und das war Wire.
Die waren eigentlich
schon relativ schnell dabei, irgendwie
alle Features zu haben. Du konntest
irgendwie malen, du hattest einen Webclient,
du hattest Videokonferenz.
Irgendwie hat es
ein bisschen schwammig angefühlt.
Die hatten immer Open Source mit versprochen.
Das kam halt dann irgendwie nie. Ich meine,
ich habe irgendwie noch so 2018 im Kopf, war das
lange versprochen, da kommt das. Und dann ja,
drei Jahre später. Also es kann sein, dass
Wire irgendwie ein Riesending ist, aber wir haben
es irgendwie gerade alle nicht auf dem Schirm, deswegen können wir es jetzt
hier in dieser Runde nicht angemessen
repräsentieren. Oder Flo, weißt du irgendwas über Wire?
Ich weiß ein bisschen
was über Wire. Ich weiß,
dass die Rust nutzen und deswegen wahrscheinlich bei dir
mit in der Babel sind.
Die sitzen ja hier in Berlin.
Achso. Das Rust-Mieter war auch häufiger
mal da. Ja,
denen geht es wohl ganz gut.
Ich
Blick, in welche Richtung das geht. Ich habe das Gefühl, die sind
ein bisschen in Richtung Enterprise gegangen.
Also, so, wir machen hier
mehr. Stimmt, die wollten. Also, da, wo
Threema eigentlich auch hin möchte. Die wollten mehr
Firmenkunden abholen und hatten
dann auch ihre Webseite auf sowas umgestellt.
Das hatte ich auch noch mitbekommen, das stimmt. Ich sehe
auch hier gerade, Threema gibt es im App Store
zweimal. Das gibt einmal Threema,
das Secure Messenger für vier Euro.
Und es gibt Threema Work, das ist
Secure Enterprise Messaging, das ist umsonst.
Das ist wahrscheinlich, weil es wahrscheinlich nur
funktioniert, wenn deine Firma das
die Lizenz zahlt.
Sonst ist es
ziemlich genau dasselbe Ding.
Und
Wire verwende ich relativ selten,
aber funktioniert gut, funktioniert auch im Browser gut.
Insofern
scheint
zu leben, aber ansonsten kann ich dazu
nicht so viel sagen. Wir haben zwischendurch mal
eine, ich glaube auch eine Axolotl
Implementierung in Rust. Genau.
Das war nämlich das, was mir
aufgefallen war damals. Die hatten
Axolotl geportet.
Das ist ja auch mit so das
Nonplusultra mittlerweile geworden,
der
Crypto-Algorithms.
Ich würde eher sagen, das ist eine Checkbox,
die man haben muss mittlerweile.
Das heißt ja mittlerweile auch nicht mehr
Axolotl, sondern hat einen anderen Namen bekommen.
Olm.
Hm? Olm.
Och, Olm, danke.
Und ich würde fast hier
diese Liste aufnehmen, also wenn es nicht Axolotl
spricht, oder wenn es nicht Olm,
da würde ich es lieber Axolotl
dann
würde ich es fast nicht benutzen,
wohl zumindest nicht als so Direct Messenger.
So vielleicht als Group Chat
hat es nochmal ein bisschen andere
Requirements und Constraints, aber
womit wir beim nächsten wären, also bei Threema
wissen wir nicht, ob die Olm oder Axolotl sprechen.
Wahrscheinlich irgendwo, ich verwerte was,
das war ihr eigenes Ding damals,
aber irgendwo dokumentiert ist es bestimmt,
wir sind bloß nicht die
zu Hauf Threema Nutzer hier.
Genau, wo wir jetzt zu einem
kommt der... Ganz kurz noch
dazu noch.
Es gibt ja
ein paar technische Neuigkeiten.
Zum Beispiel gibt es ja jetzt inzwischen den
Message Layer Security Standard, also
BTLS nur für Einzelnachrichten.
MLS.
Also nicht für Verbindungen, sondern für Nachrichten.
Und an einer der Implementierungen
OpenMLS sind einige von den Wire-Leuten
beteiligt. Ich weiß allerdings nicht,
wie das als Verhältnis zu
der Firma aussieht oder sonst was. Ist mir nur
aufgefallen, dass einige
Leute daran beteiligt sind. Ich würde es mal
in den Shownotes verlinken. Also
aus der Protokollebene tun sich schon einige Sachen
und die IETF ist auf jeden Fall
mal drin an der Sache.
Inzwischen bei Draft 11.
Das geht quasi bei 9.
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht. Oh, das ist ein
krasses Dokument, das muss ich mal lesen.
Genau, also
30 Jahre
nachdem Chats
groß geworden sind, beschäftigt sich die IETF
endlich mal mit verschlüsselten Chats.
Krass. Aber schön, dass da
überhaupt was passiert.
Da sind Leute von Facebook, Google und Cisco
dabei. Oh nein, die haben Cisco
da.
Kann's ja nichts werden.
Cisco hat natürlich auch irgendwie so
ein Steak im Feuer wahrscheinlich.
Du meinst mit Cisco Jabber? Genau.
Das war jemand von euch genutzt?
Cisco Jabber? Ja, es war irgendwie
überall mit installiert, wenn du
irgendwie so Cisco-Netzwerkzeug installiert
hast, dann gab's das noch mit dazu. Oder es läuft
auf irgendwelchen Telefonen, die im Büro stehen.
Aber nee.
Cisco Jabber habe ich
eine ganze Weile verwendet.
Sehr angenehm.
Also,
sagen wir es mal so, es kriegt Nachrichten
von A nach B, es ist
unverschlüsselt und lügt da wenigstens nicht.
Es ist ja auch
aus einer Zeit, wo nichts verschlüsselt war.
Das muss man noch dazu sagen.
Es geht sehr transparent mit deinen Daten um.
Gut.
Was ist denn bei WhatsApp passiert?
Das steht hier als nächstes auf unserer Liste und ich wollte
so ein bisschen den Übergang machen und sagen,
wo wir gerade bei Sachen sind, die angeblich
Ulm
verwenden.
Ist okay, wenn ich mal da absoluten sage, ganz im Herzen.
WhatsApp hat ja jetzt
endlich nach drei Jahren
beschlossen, typischer
Facebook-Bild und Switch,
die Userdaten
zu verkaufen und das hat ja zu einem leichten
User-Exodus geführt, wobei das wahrscheinlich bei
das waren für Facebook wahrscheinlich Promille-Anteile
für alle anderen
riesen Gruppen.
Oh Gott, wir müssen neue Server hochfahren.
Man hat es sehr stark gemerkt,
bei Signal sind die Anmelde-Server
mal abendlang
sehr schleichend gewesen und bei
Matrix.org hat man es auch gemerkt.
Wir sind da reingelaufen, weil wir
für eine
Konferenz einen Matrix-Server betrieben haben
und
ja, die Federation
mit Matrix.org wurde so schleichend dadurch,
dass plötzlich auf dem
Standard-Matrix.org-Homeserver
so viele neue User waren,
dass es
so war, dass wenn Leute unseren
Homeserver mit ihrem Account
von Matrix.org verwendet haben,
circa vier bis fünf Mal
so langsam war, wenn sie sich einfach bei uns
direkt angemeldet haben. Ja, die Erfahrung habe ich selber
auf die Konferenz rumgerannt und haben gesagt, könnt ihr bitte euren Account
nochmal neu anmelden und zwar bei uns und das
könnt ihr übrigens so und so und so und so machen.
Das ist ja ein Fünf-Schritte-Prozess.
irgendwie, da muss man allen
Leuten sagen, dass ich bitte einen neuen Account
auf unserem Homeserver anlegen soll,
womit wir wieder bei meinem Punkt vom letzten Mal
wären. Ich kann mit Federation nichts anfangen,
es macht nur Probleme.
Es ist so,
also wenn ich am Anfang meinte,
dass viele Sachen kaputt sind, das waren für mich
über die Jahre immer so ein paar
Kriterien, die ich gerne erfüllt
haben würde von einem Netzwerk, beziehungsweise
von einem Protokoll oder einem Client oder wie auch immer,
einem Service und
Federation war halt einer der Punkte,
Also die Tatsache, dass ich nicht nur mit Leuten am selben Netzwerk sprechen kann,
sondern dass auch andere Leute anderswo sein können.
Wir kennen das Konzept von E-Mail.
Als Gmail-Nutzer kann ich nicht nur an andere Gmail-Nutzer-Mails schicken,
obwohl Google das bestimmt gerne demnächst mal das Feature aktivieren würde.
Würde mich nicht wundern.
Die paar Nutzer, die noch nicht Gmail verwenden, die brauchen wir auch nicht mehr.
Aber es ist doch was Schönes, Freies.
Und manche Netzwerke bringen das eben mit.
Bei Jabba ist das so, bei Matrix ist das so.
Aber bei vielen Services ist es halt nicht so.
Und ich erinnere mich an die schönen alten Zeiten
als Facebook-Chat, Google-Chat, das war alles XMPP anfangs.
Da haben wir uns gedacht, boah, ist das geil.
Da war sogar Federation offen.
Ich konnte von meinem Google-Chat-Account
einen Facebook-Nutzer anschreiben.
Und das war der Hammer, dass das halt ging.
Und das fand ich richtig, richtig cool.
Irgendwann sind die alle davon wegmigriert,
weil wahrscheinlich, also meine Vermutung damals war,
Gruppenchats waren ekelhaft mit XMPP aufzuziehen.
Und da haben sie halt dann angefangen,
auf ihr proprietäres Ding umzusteigen.
Es war, glaube ich, einfacher, schnell selber was zu bauen,
als das irgendwie als Feature in diesen XMPP-Standard mit reinzukriegen.
Du bist dann halt mit solchen Standards leider,
und das sieht man beim Web, da gab es ja auch am Anfang,
als die Browser losgingen, irgendwie diesen Run,
wo die Browser alle ihre eigenen Sachen eingebaut haben.
Wenn du Innovationen machen möchtest,
und du musst es aber irgendwie in so einen gemeinsamen Stand,
den alle implementieren, mit reinbringen,
dann bist du gewisserweise ein bisschen ausgebremst.
This page is optimized for Internet Explorer 6.
Genau, best with Nintendo 647.
Zwischendurch gab es dann die Meldung,
dass man sich bitte den Firefox runterladen sollte.
Das waren noch die echten Browser-Kriege hier.
Und dann hat jeder Browser behauptet, er sei Mosaic.
Und dann, ja.
Ja, nee, aber Federation fand ich immer ein schönes Feature.
Ich stehe dir absolut zu,
dass das Federation an sich höllisch kompliziert ist
und sehr viele Probleme aufwirft,
wenn man auf der anderen Seite sitzt.
Aber aus Nutzersicht ist das ein Feature,
was sehr viel Freiheit bietet und sehr viele schöne Sachen ermöglicht.
Und genau, also für Federation ist das eine.
Was mir persönlich immer noch wichtig war, ist natürlich Verschlüsselung,
dass das irgendwie möglich ist.
Ich nutze auch Clients, die das nicht können.
Telegram zum Beispiel, haha, kommen wir gleich bestimmt nochmal zu.
Aber es ist trotzdem, das ist eine Box, die relativ groß ist.
Und wenn die gecheckt wird, dann ist das sehr viel mehr wert,
dass man das benutzen kann und sich gut damit fühlt.
Und ein offenes Ecosystem im Sinne von Third-Party-Clients möglich ist natürlich nochmal sehr viel schöner, aber das ist dann immer noch das i-Typflchen gewesen.
Und für mich waren das immer so die drei Aspekte, die von nichts irgendwie erfüllt wurden, bis man irgendwann bestimmte Dinge wie Matrix entdeckt hat, wo das halt wieder eine Möglichkeit darstellt.
Aber wie gesagt, das hatte mich damals tierisch genervt, dass ich mir mein Google-Chat-Account nicht mehr Facebook-Notal anschreiben konnte.
Ich war das richtig doof.
Deshalb haben sie so schön zu einem...
Gab es so diesen kurzen Moment der Hoffnung?
Das Internet ist so offen.
Das Internet ist super.
Alle benutzen diese kompatible Technologie
und ich kann niemanden, der auf...
Also ich hatte keine Ahnung, was Jabba oder XMPP waren
zu dem Zeitpunkt. Ich habe überhaupt keinen
Peil von, aber ich kann einfach mit
anderen Chat-Netzwerken sprechen und das war
der Hammer. Das war aber großartig.
Ja, ich habe grundsätzlich mit
Federation auch mehr so ein Problem,
weil das so
das klassische Feature ist, wo
Hinz und Kunst, die mal
spontan neues Jet-Protokoll-Design,
machen als erstes mal Federation rein
und am Ende sind irgendwie alle Features mau
und das kann Federation und sonst nichts.
Wenn man die anstellt, irgendwie schlecht.
Ja, einmal das.
Ich hatte das letzte Mal auch angemerkt,
Moderation in federierten Systemen ist schwierig.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe auch den Eindruck,
deine Aussage trifft so ein bisschen auf Matrix zu,
weil die könnten irgendwie von Anfang an Federation,
aber sonst irgendwie extrem viel einfach nicht.
Es gibt auch jetzt viele Sachen,
die andere Sachen können,
bei Matrix einfach nicht gehen.
Lass uns später mal viel Zeit mit Matrix
verbringen, weil da hat sich wirklich, wirklich
viel getan und zwar auch gar nicht.
Ich meine, der letzte
Mal hatten wir das Runt Bubble genannt
und ich habe eigentlich über Matrix relativ
wenig zu ranten momentan
über die letzten Jahre. Da hat sich
wirklich viel zum Positiven verwandelt.
Auch wenn wir natürlich in diese
unser Federation-Protokoll
underperformen, wenn
bald schnell halt WhatsApp
onboardet.
Es ist schon absolut richtig, was du meinst, dass das Federation Dinge schwierig macht in der Hinsicht. Das ist ja auch eines der Hauptargumente von Moxie, dem Menschen, könnte man so sagen, im Kopf hinter das Signal, Moxie Malenspike, der hatte auf dem letzten In-Person-Congress und hatte auch von vorher als Talk gehalten.
Der heißt jetzt nur noch IPC.
Der IPC, genau, der Imperson Congress.
Beziehungsweise der hat das vorher auch schon als Blogpost veröffentlicht gehabt.
Da hat er quasi noch seinen Blogpost nochmal in Talkform gehalten,
warum er der Meinung ist, dass das Federation eine schlechte Idee sei
und warum Signal das nie machen wird und warum Signal so ist, wie Signal ist.
Das ist auch okay an der Stelle.
Es ist okay, wenn das seine Meinung ist.
Ich fand, viele von den Aussagen von ihm ließen sich gut debanken.
Aber die Grundidee war halt die, dass Federation es schwierig macht, neue Features zu entwickeln, die potenziell halt die Spec ändern, weil du dann halt daran gebunden bist, dass das jeder mitzieht. Ganz grob gesagt. Und wenn das halt schwierig umsetzbar ist oder sich sehr lang erstreckt, dann kannst du halt langsamer dein Protokoll evolven. Logisch, ist richtig.
Man merkt, dass der Mensch mal bei Twitter gearbeitet hat. Es wird das ja mit seiner API genauso umgesprungen. Ich finde das Argument sehr schwierig, weil das dann natürlich auch dazu führt, dass man halt auch dann sagen muss, Third-Party-Clients lassen wir nicht zu und so weiter und so fort.
Und aus kommerzieller Sicht hat er da durchaus recht. Du möchtest Features pushen und je länger du brauchst, um Feature zu pushen, desto später kannst du es kommerzialisieren.
Das Problem ist, du möchtest unter Umständen alternative Clients, wir reden jetzt einfach mal nur über Accessibility-Sachen.
Zum Beispiel, es gibt spezielle Clients für spezielle Accessibility-Needs und so weiter und so fort. Und entweder, also da möchte ich halt dann das Gegenargument bringen, wenn er gerne so viele Leute einstellen möchte, dass er all diese Needs mit seinem Client auch alle abdeckt, dann kann er das gerne tun.
Das wird aber nicht passieren bei Signal. Also ja, klar, das wäre natürlich schön, als jemand, der aktuell quasi an einem Third-Party-Signal-Client mit irgendwie halb beteiligt ist, sage ich mal, dass das auch tricky ist, aber ich verstehe natürlich, also du kannst natürlich, was Moxie auch mit gemeint hatte war, dass du halt bei Third-Party-Clients nicht die, also Signal hat zum Beispiel Disappearing Messages als Feature, was auch ein schönes, nettes Feature ist, aber das kannst du halt nicht garantieren, wenn dein Gegenüber nicht den Signal
Client nutzt. Gut, das kannst du so oder so nie
wirklich garantieren,
dass die Nachrichten auch wirklich verschwinden, aber
du kannst eine bessere Aussage darüber treffen,
wenn du weißt oder wenn du vorschreibst,
dass alle den offiziellen Client nutzen,
der das halt auch als Feature mit implementiert
und nicht anders damit umgeht.
Das funktioniert halt
anderweitig nicht.
Ja gut, aber ich kann den offiziellen Client immer noch screenshotten.
Auch das geht, logisch.
Ja, wie gesagt, garantieren kannst du
so oder so nie, aber
du kannst, vielleicht nicht das beste
Beispiel, die Disappearing Messages, weil ja klar,
die Screenshots umgehen ist relativ easy,
aber ja.
Ich finde die
eigentlich ja kein schlechtes Beispiel, weil
ich verwende Disappearing Messages mit
verschiedenen Leuten auf Signal, aber das ist ein sozialer
Kontrakt. Also das passiert mir ganz
häufig, also insbesondere mit Leuten,
die
da Wert drauflegen.
Signal Gruppe geht auf und als allererstes kommt mal
das Kurzgespräch über, was sind unsere
Disappearing-Messages-Einstellungen?
Ich sag's mal einfach so,
nachdem wir dieses Gespräch gehabt haben,
ist es ganz klar, das sollte ich mal irgendwann
einen Screenshot von so einer Nachricht irgendwo posten.
Dann ist diese Beziehung schwer beschädigt.
Es ist absolut richtig.
Natürlich hat die andere Person immer noch nicht
die Garantie, dass ich jetzt wirklich
den offiziellen Signal-Client verwende,
dieses Feature auch ordentlich implementiert
und so weiter und so fort.
Schwierige Kiste.
Insofern finde ich das
ein etwas
flaches Argument, wenn er wenigstens
sagen würde, wir bauen hier nicht den
Basis-Messaging-Layer der Zukunft,
wir warten mal, dass das jemand anders
macht, vielleicht
das Signal dann irgendwann hin und setzt auf das Matrix-Protokoll
oder auf die nächste Version
von XMPP.
Nein, natürlich nicht, aber
das
Und auf der anderen Seite finde ich es auch ein bisschen absurd vor dem Hintergrund.
Hat sich an der Signal-App in den letzten drei Jahren was verändert?
Naja, wenn wir jetzt schon bei Signal sind.
Klar, du hast hier sehr schön reingeschrieben, nichts Neues außer Krypto.
Ja, es ist ja nichts dazu gekommen.
Also die ist immer noch hässlich.
Ich nehme dir noch tatsächlich ein bisschen arg übel, was sie mit der Desktop-App damals gemacht hatten.
Dass das halt anfangs eine Chrome-Packaged-App war.
Also nicht mal eine Electron-App, was sie aktuell ist, sondern eine Chrome-Packaged-App.
Sprich so eine App, die du nur betreiben kannst, wenn Chrome im Hintergrund gerade aktiv läuft.
Und also die lief nur, wenn Google Spyware läuft.
Und das fand ich einfach nur richtig dreckig.
Gerade von Signal.
Also von anderen Sachen hätte ich...
Also wenn WhatsApp das gemacht hätte, meinetwegen wäre ungeil gewesen,
aber meinetwegen passt irgendwie ins Konzept.
Aber gerade von Signal, das verzeih ich dir heute noch nicht.
Ja, also die Coin-Sache, um gerade kurz ins Detail zu gehen.
Also in Großbritannien ist es jetzt, glaube ich, kann man sich über Signal Geld schicken.
MobileCoin.
Und
was ich sehr
schwierig finde an der Stelle ist,
sie haben sehr unklar
kommuniziert, wie diese Verbindung eigentlich
zusammengekommen ist.
Du meinst politisch gesehen, also wie es zu MobileCoin
kam für Signal? Genau, also erst hat man ihr gesagt,
man hat diese Signal Foundation gegründet,
damit Signal von einer
Foundation gemanagt wird und so weiter und so fort.
Also um da so ein bisschen mehr Governance zu schaffen.
Die Governance von Signal ist mir immer noch völlig
unklar, muss ich ehrlich gesagt sagen, also dass es
Foundation gibt.
Und
jetzt ist Moxie Investor in
MobileCoin und plötzlich taucht
das Startup, in das er investiert hat,
in Signal auf,
was eigentlich mehr so in die
Richtung deutet,
er hat da doch noch ziemlich viel
Power und nutzt die
halt auch mal gerne, wenn es opportun ist.
Das ist, sag ich mal, schwierig.
Das ist echt ein wenig unschön,
auf jeden Fall.
Ich wollte gerade noch hinzufügen, bei der Signal-App
wenigstens in den letzten Jahren
so ein paar kosmetische Sachen in der Usability
passiert, irgendwie, dass man
jetzt irgendwie seine Nachrichten
pinnen kann und dass man auf Gruppenchats
oder auf Chats allgemein
so die Zusammenfassung mit allen Medien,
die man sich hin und her geschickt hat,
nachträglich angucken kann.
Was war es eigentlich für einen Signal-Bug letztens, als
dein Client plötzlich alle uralten Gruppen
wieder mit allen Kontakten aufgemacht hat?
Das war ein lustiger Bug.
Ich bin in diesen
Beta-Tester-Modus gegangen und habe die über Testflight
installiert. Und jetzt sagt
mir Testflight ab und zu mal beim Starten
hier so und so, das musst du machen, wenn du Bugs findest.
Teste mal. Und dann gingen irgendwie
bei mir alle, habe ich
Nachrichten bekommen. So und so hatte ich zu einer
Gruppe, die vor drei Jahren mal relevant war,
hinzugefügt. Andere
Leute haben die Nachrichten bekommen.
Hendrik hat dich zu dieser Gruppe hinzugefügt.
Ich habe bei mir was genau so. Hendrik hat dich zu Hendrik
zieht um. Was? Hendrik zieht um?
Genau.
Das war eine Gruppe, die war, da war eigentlich
nichts mehr los. Da musste ich dann reinschreiben. Nee.
aber danke, dass ihr mir nochmal eure Hilfe
angeboten habt
also das mit den Gruppen
ist irgendwie auch so halb kaputt
ja das stimmt, also die Semantik
von Signal ist immer noch
One-to-One-Messages und
Chatgruppen sind immer noch
irgendwie ein bisschen
schlecht unterstützt. Das ist ja witzigerweise auch die
Krypto von Signal
Olm ist ja so implementiert, dass du quasi an alle
Gruppenteilnehmer die Nachricht verschlüsselst
und deswegen hat Signal auch ein hartes
Limit von 250 Teilnehmern pro Gruppe
und ab 100
merkst du halt wirklich schon, du spürst halt
Performance-Unterschiede.
Weil es ein 8-Bit-Schlüssel ist oder warum?
Weiß ich nicht.
Es gab mal diesen wunderbaren
Nachrichtenartikel, dass irgendwie
Gruppengrößen 255 Leute sind
und irgendwo im Artikel stand,
das ist ein ordentlich specific number, weil der Journalist
wohl nicht erkannt hat, was das für eine
Zahl ist.
Das sind so Zahlen, die werfen dich halt
nicht vor Fragen, wenn du irgendwie
passenden Kontext hast, aber als jeder halt nur so, what?
Also ich muss
sagen, also
die Qualität des Chats auf Signal
fasse ich mal so zusammen, dass ich
Signal rein als
Voice-Over-IP-App verwende. Ah, okay.
Weil die, also
von
egal welchem Ort zu egal welchem
Ort auf dieser Erde kriegen die sehr ordentliche
Voice-Over-IP-Calls hin.
Und da meine Mutter
zeitweise momentan nicht in Botswana
wohnt und ich auch hin und
wieder mal in anderen Ecken mit schlechtem Netzwerk
bin, das funktioniert wirklich super.
Also da muss man wirklich mal loben.
Auch richtig in
crappiestes WLAN
3G sonst wo im afrikanischen
Busch nach irgendwo sonst was.
Kein Problem.
Nicht schlecht.
Vor allem halt,
ja, also
entsprechend habe ich all meine Kontakte nochmal auf Signal,
aber chatte mit ihnen woanders.
Ja, sag lieber das aus, was du
von Signal's Chat hältst.
Was man halt auch
anrechnen muss, ist diese
Censorship Protection. Das war ja von immer so ein größeres Ding
bei Signal, dass sie darauf halt
mit Wert legen und da Features bauen, dass
du das halt nutzen kannst in Ländern,
die halt versuchen, das zu unterbinden.
Und sowas hast du halt,
also das habe ich noch bei keinem anderen Messenger je gesehen.
Das sind, glaube ich, so die Sachen, die sie auch als
Entwicklungsprojekte immer vorgezogen haben
und dementsprechend ihre UX
und UI so ein bisschen vernachlässigen.
Ja genau, also auch diese GIF-Suche damals, wo sie halt sehr explizit darauf hingewiesen haben, beziehungsweise sehr, sehr schön dokumentiert haben, wie sie das halt implementiert haben, dass du weder Signal-Server noch den GIFI-Servern irgendwelche Daten von dir gibst.
Also das wird ja, das war irgendwie so technisch richtig cool, dass du das quasi durch den Signal-Server durchschleifst zu Giphy, damit der Giphy-Server nicht weiß, wer du bist, aber der Signal-Server soll ja nicht wissen, was du bei einem GIF suchst und so weiter, deswegen schicken die da haufenweise Garbage mit, aber nutzen HTTP-Range-Header, um zu sagen, was dann tatsächlich der eigentlich relevante Teil des Requests ist und das aber dann dem Signal-Server gegenüber verschlüsselt, aber der Giphy-Server hatte zufällig, also haben sie irgendwie so beschrieben, dass sie nicht erwartet haben, dass das funktioniert,
aber der GIF-Server hat halt die Spec richtig verstanden
und hat halt mit dem Range halt dann die richtigen
Teile halt rausgezogen. Und das fand ich halt
technisch super cool, wie sie das halt gelöst haben.
Da stecken sie halt wirklich Arbeit
dran. Das ist auch sehr cool, ohne Frage.
Aber der Rest muss halt auch irgendwo funktionieren.
Als du gerade erzählt hast, dass du das hauptsächlich für
Voice-Over-IP benutzt, ist bei mir natürlich erstmal
mein WebRTC-Herz kurz hochgeschlagen und ich
hab mir gedacht, hm, ich frag mich, welche SFU
Signal verwendet. Was ist SFU?
Welche Selective Forwarding
Unit, also das WebRTC-Backend.
Ob das, weil es wahrscheinlich, wenn es gut funktioniert ist, ist es eventuell nicht eins zu eins Peer-to-Peer.
So meine Vermutung.
Also, was ich, ich meine, man muss sich an den Stellen immer loben.
Ich meine, auch vor kurzem die Sache mit Celebrite.
Stimmt, ja.
Celebrite ist ja ein Toolkit zum Extrahieren von Nachrichten von Telefonen.
Und sie haben sich das mal genau angeschaut und haben mal geguckt, was eigentlich passiert, wenn sie da einfach mal so ein bisschen Junk schicken.
Und haben festgestellt, dass die Celebrite-App an sich nicht so gut implementiert ist und dass man die Daten auf der anderen Seite ganz einfach schlicht und einfach fälschen kann.
Was wahrscheinlich jeden Strafverteidiger...
Das können wir mal in die Show-Notes packen.
Da gibt es auch eine schöne Zusammenfassung in einem Logbuch Netzpolitik dazu oder in dem Blogpost von ihm.
Ich habe das an meinen Anwalt geschickt.
Also der ist jetzt kein Strafverteidiger und er so, oh, das ist wirklich schön.
Vor allem, weil sie es auch genau auf die Art und Weise zusammenfassen, dass sie halt auch einfach, sie haben es dann ja auch, also im Prinzip war das ein Counter-Hack, wenn das Ding feststellt, Satellite redet hier mit uns, dann schicken wir aktiv falsche Daten.
Und das Schöne ist, sie haben es ja auch auf eine Art und Weise dokumentiert, auf der das auch weiterverwendbar ist.
Der war auch so herrlich geschrieben.
Also am Anfang so, wir haben da ganz zufällig
hier diese Kiste Celebrite-Sachen
hier auf der Straße gefunden, das vom Laster
gefallen hat, auch so ein Bild, wie das halt einfach
auf der Straße liegt. Und
sie hat noch am Ende auch irgendwas geschrieben von wegen, es gibt
auch, wenn du eine bestimmte Datei, die
irgendwie bestimmt formatiert ist oder benannt ist oder irgendwie
mit in deinem App-Bundle hast auf iOS.
Das war eigentlich das Hauptsächliche, was ich gehört habe, dass du
ich muss diesen Blogpost mal lesen.
Dann schmiert das Celebrite-SDK ab.
Celebrite hat halt einen Parser und die haben halt
analysiert, was gibt es da für Schwachstellen
in dem Parser und wenn wir
jetzt in unseren Code, der von deren Parser
gelesen wird,
das und das reintun, dann
exploiten wir den Parser und dann
können wir Remote Code Execution
bei der Polizei machen oder so eine Art.
Und dann gab es halt ganz am Ende des Blogposts
diesen herrlichen Absatz, der nichts damit
zu tun hatte, completely unrelated news.
Upcoming versions of Signal will be periodically
fetching files to place in an App Storage.
These files are never used for anything inside Signal
and never interact with Signal Software, but they
nice. Anesthetics are important in Software.
Hat überhaupt nichts
mit dem Rest des Posts zu tun, aber vielleicht
nur unter Umständen könnte man mal
eine random Datei bei uns mit dem
App-Bundle finden, aber die hat natürlich nichts damit zu tun.
Also man muss an der Stelle sagen, dass
mit dem nichts Neues außer Krypto
stimmt nicht ganz.
Ein paar Sachen machen sie schon, die irgendwie geil sind,
muss ich sagen.
Aus der Produktsicht schon. Also das Problem,
das ich immer mit Signal ein bisschen habe, ist,
warum
sind sie nicht wirklich den Weg gegangen, wir
Standardkomponenten und versuchen, solche Sachen
zu standardisieren.
Das haben sie ja gemacht.
Das haben sie ja mit Olm slash Axolotl getan.
Das ist ja jetzt so der Standard geworden
für viele Messenger mit.
Ja, aber ich habe nicht
das Gefühl, dass sie das sehr aktiv machen.
Also solche
Warte, war da nicht
mit Wire damals auch irgendwie so ein Ding,
dass Wire das nachgebaut hatte
und Signal hatte denen irgendwie eine Klage vor die Füße
geworfen oder irgendwas?
Also ich hatte nur eine Aussage
Moxie von auch vor vier oder fünf Jahren
im Hinterkopf, dass die gesagt haben, also
wenn irgendwie die anderen Messenger
Axolotl einbauen, dann können wir mit Signal
auch wieder aufhören, weil dann haben wir unser Ziel erreicht.
Der wollte, der hat auch aktiv
WhatsApp gepusht irgendwann. Ich meine,
Facebook hatte ja sich bei, tatsächlich bei
der, die hießen
damals noch anders, die
jetzt komme ich nicht mehr drauf, wie Signal
oder die Signal Foundation hieß, aber spielt auch keine Rolle,
sich gemeldet und die haben damit
mit denen kooperiert und Krypto
was eingebaut und dann, ich meine,
das war halt irgendwie nicht auditable damals, aber
Moxie hat sich halt hingestellt von wegen hier,
WhatsApp ist jetzt safe,
ihr könnt jetzt alle WhatsApp benutzen.
Ich meine, es ist ja gut,
das von der Seite anzugehen,
wenn die Leute eh WhatsApp nutzen, da einen soliden
Unterbau drunter zu bauen. Es ist trotzdem
hässlich, wenn sich Moxie hinstellt und Werbung für Facebook
macht.
Naja, konnte ja niemand wissen,
dass sie die Userdaten drei Jahre später dann verkaufen
würden.
Hier, sorry,
instant Feedback von mir selber,
Moxie, die Open Whisper
Systems, so hießen die damals,
didn't threaten to sue WIRE, WIRE sued
Open Whisper Systems,
und dann ging es halt ein bisschen komisch
hinterher, ich packe mal ein Hacker News
Kommentar mit dem Link einfach mit dazu,
ein bisschen Kontext hier,
in die Shownotes.
Ja, ich
kann, ich glaube,
mein großes Problem mit Signal ist, dass ich sie immer noch nicht ganz
platzieren kann. Sind sie jetzt eigentlich
Produkt oder sind sie da irgendwie so ein
Zentralpunkt oder sonst was?
Sind sie Activism oder sind sie
haben sie wirtschaftliche Interessen?
Genau und
wer hat da jetzt eigentlich
was
in der Hand und so weiter und so fort?
Ja.
Das ist richtig.
Was mir gerade noch einfällt, was du vorhin
meintest von wegen Signal hat potenziell
gar nicht die Ressourcen dazu,
eine App zu bauen, die allein schon aus Accessibility-Gründen
her alles abdecken würde, mal von
anderen Gründen für Third-Party-Clients abgesehen.
Das fand ich bei Facebook
damals recht cool. Ich war
einmal zu Besuch mit im
Facebook HQ, hab einfach mal eine Tour mitgemacht
und mach Spaßenshalber
und das fand ich einfach
ein Detail, was mir im Kopf geblieben ist, dass die da
in einem der Großraumbüros,
aber sicherlich auch in vielen anderen Stellen,
einfach so einen Tisch rumliegen hatten
mit richtig schrottiger sonst was
Hardware. Hardware, die halt wirklich so
Einsteiger-Android-Geräte, die halt auch in
dritten Weltländern populär ist.
Und es gab Tage, wo halt Facebook-Employees
dazu angeregt wurden, die die Apps
und die Software und die Webseite auch darauf zu
dogfooden, einfach um Awareness
zu schaffen, auch in der Firma für, es nutzt
nicht jeder hier die High-End-Hardware-Mobil-
Geräte, die wir uns leisten, sondern die wir
uns privat in die In-The-Taste stecken haben, sondern auch
ganz andere Sachen und da soll es natürlich auch gut laufen.
Und ich meine, damit
haben sie das endlich auch geschafft, dass
ich glaube, Facebook-Lite gab es
damals sogar irgendwann mal. Das war irgendwie so ein
abgespecktes Ding, was auf noch weniger
lief, auf noch weniger Basis.
Und in vielen Ländern,
gerade ich meine im Pazifik-Raum,
ist es immer so ein Vorurteil,
dass Facebook das Internet
ist. Also Menschen da,
die gehen ins Internet, das heißt für
die halt, die öffnen Facebook und bleiben da in Kontakt
mit anderen Menschen oder posten halt irgendwelche Sachen
und der Rest des Internets interessiert die halt nicht.
Und Facebook hat es halt geschafft, so diesen Stand zu bekommen,
weil die halt auch mit
drauf gekommen sind, dass man halt wirklich
Menschen ansprechen müssen. Das ist halt
ein nobles Ziel, auf jeden Fall.
Was daraus geworden ist, kann man sich darüber streiten, aber
das finde ich schon stark von denen, dass
die da halt auch den Fokus drauf gelegt haben.
Aber das ist was,
was nicht nur Facebook macht. Ne, sicher nicht.
Diese Krabbelkiste mit,
das wohl sortierte Geräteregal
mit den
QA-Geräten, wo das,
wo wir wissen, bis hier
muss die Software noch laufen und
in drei Wochen können wir das Gerät
rausnehmen und in die nicht mehr Supported
zu tun, das machen auch andere.
Ja, bei Facebook ist halt explizit, ich glaube,
die Idee war immer, es gibt keine Liste
von nicht-supporteten Geräten. Facebook soll
bitte überall laufen.
Das stimmt.
Kennt ihr an der Stelle
ein bisschen
Zeit-Track, kennt ihr Google Go?
Also die Sprache.
Das war dieser Assistent, oder?
Es ist nämlich nicht die Programmiersprache,
sondern das ist die Variante der
Google-Suchmaschine für, also
der Google-App für
Länder mit geringen Bandbreiten
kleinen Devices, die ist irgendwie 6 Megabyte groß
oder sonst was, und die heißt Google Go.
Witzig.
Und das ist nicht die Programmiersprache.
Google hat also zwei Produkte namens Go.
Mindestens.
Ich dachte, Go war dieser Assistent,
der mit auf Android mit drauf war,
der irgendwie erraten
hat, was du jetzt als nächstes Mal,
der so eine Art Siri-Ersatz war quasi.
Das, was Okay Google dann geworden ist, oder was?
Eventuell, ja. Aber gut, Naming
und Produkte von Google bin ich nicht so ganz hinterher.
Go passt halt bei denen so oder so,
als die ersten zwei Buchstaben des Namens.
Wie viele von den Messengern, die wir hier aufzählen,
haben übrigens einen Client für KaiOS,
wo wir gerade so für den Zweite-Welt-Markt besprechen.
Ein Matrix-Client gibt es, soweit ich weiß.
Es gibt auch einen Matrix-Client für Nintendo 3DS.
Hol mich kurz ab.
KaiOS ist das der Nachfolger von Firefox OS?
Genau, KaiOS ist das, was die Leute aus Firefox OS gemacht haben.
Sehr schön
Ein random Detail, sorry, dass ich mal ganz kurz noch
backtrack, was mir gerade noch eingefallen ist, weil ich es witzig fand
das war vielleicht
sogar schon mal ein Pick hier im Podcast
da hatte jemand
TCP over
Facebook Chat gebaut
also quasi, du hast
kein Internet, aber du hast Zugang zu Facebook Messenger
klar, kein Problem, hier ist
Internet
Also
KaiOS ist mir bloß im Kopf
um diesen
Tangent noch zu beenden, weil man sich
dieses wunderschöne Nokia
8110 Feature Phone
mit KaiWassel, was das Banana Phone
ist, was man, was so dieses
schöne Gelbton
aus dem Matrix Phone ist, wo man, was man
unten, ja, das aus
aus dem Film Matrix,
genau, und da habe ich mir überlegt,
eigentlich nur, weil es geil ist, hätte ich gerne so ein Telefon
nur, um irgendwo sagen zu können, das nicht,
dann würde ich nämlich sagen, Smartphone,
ne, damit machst du alles außer
telefonieren. Und zum Telefonieren würde ich dann auch so
ein Telefon dabei haben. Nur weil es geil aussieht.
Und damit du dein Display nicht irgendwie an dein
fettiges Gesicht halten musst.
Ring, ring, ring, ring, ring, ring.
Was haben wir denn als nächstes auf unserer Liste?
Ja, weil wir das das letzte Mal angesprochen haben,
sollte man vielleicht noch kurz über Sulib reden.
Sulib? Oh, habe ich auch noch mal nicht mehr gehört.
Sulib gibt es immer noch. Was zum Geier ist das?
Das war auch so ein Team-Chat, aber der
ein sehr cooles Konzept hatte,
dass er sehr auf Threads ausgelegt war.
Ich bin ja auf zwei großen
Sulib-Servern.
Ach was, du nutzt das.
Das RAS-Projekt, das wir
das letzte Mal gesprochen haben, war das RAS-Projekt
gerade dabei, Chat-Plattformen zu wechseln.
Aber ich dachte, ihr seid da zu
Matrix doch mit.
Nee.
Discord gegangen.
Wir sind am Ende zu Discord und zu Sulib gegangen.
Große Teile des Projekts sind immer noch auf unserem
Discord-Server.
Und viele der Arbeitsgruppen chatten auf
Sulib und meine Firma verwendet Sulib.
Und dabei habe ich dann sehr interessante Sachen festgestellt, weil es ist ein Enterprise-Chat.
Auf der anderen Seite ist das sehr Open-Source-Gemanaged.
Und das mixt sich manchmal ein bisschen komisch.
Und das heißt?
Naja, also wir haben zum Beispiel, es gibt ja dieses klassische, du kannst Leute in deine Kanäle einladen.
Also so Kunden, du legst dir einen Kanal an und sagst, ich würde gerne diesen Kunden hier einladen.
Und dann kriegen die nur Zugriff, dann kriegen die einen speziellen User, der nur als Guest-User registriert ist, der nur auf diese Channels und auf diese Threads Zugriff hat.
Problem, trotzdem gibt es eine globale User-Liste und aus der kannst du sehen, welche anderen alle online sind.
Also du kannst den gesamten Satz aller User auf dem Server sehen.
Das heißt, sobald du jemanden in den Chatel eingeladen hast, weißt du, wann der online ist oder wie?
Die Person weiß, wer alles bei der Firma ist.
Achso.
Du weißt vor allem, also kannst du im Prinzip die Kundenliste
sehen. Ach, das stimmt. Die anderen Gäste
sehen die ja dann auch.
Genau, mit E-Mail und
an der Stelle müssen wir dann alle immer darüber
informieren, dass das übrigens der Fall ist und wir haben
die dann auch schon mal angeschrieben und die so
ja,
können wir fixen, aber
ihr müsstet die Entwicklung bezahlen. Finde ich
ein bisschen komisch für eine Firma, die sich als Enterprise
Chat-Plattform platziert.
Also sie sind so
an der weirden Ecke zwischen
wir sind ein Produkt, für das ihr Geld bezahlt
und wir sind gleichzeitig ein Open-Source-Projekt.
Genauso sieht es mit LDAP
Active Directory Support aus.
Deswegen haben wir das damals im FSR nicht genutzt.
Also ich hatte den Fehler begangen, vor vielen Jahren
im Fachschaftsrat Informatik mal
Slack zu etablieren.
Und das war dann auch, also vorher waren wir
Diehard IRC und Jabba User.
Diehard im Sinne von, niemand hat es genutzt.
Es gab einfach keinen wirklichen Chat, es gab die Mailing-Liste
und es gab Real-Life-Gespräche.
Das Sofa war einfach zu bemütlich.
Das Richte war ja auch
keine große Organisation oder so.
Es waren einfach 30 Nerds, die irgendwie
in Kontakt bleiben wollten.
Slack hat aber wirklich richtig gut funktioniert
über viele Jahre hinweg, aber dann war immer die Suche nach
einer Alternative und alles, was man genutzt hat,
irgendwas ist halt fehlgegangen.
Wo du gerade sagst, LDAP Support hat bei Zulb, glaube ich,
damals gefehlt gehabt.
Genau, da sind sie schon mehrfach dran gelaufen.
Also deswegen haben sie an mehreren Stellen schon verloren,
aber sie fixen es immer noch nicht.
Allerdings hat Zulb eines
gute Sache, die wir gerade beim RAS-Projekt hart
bemerken.
Discord hat einfach
nur User-Level. Und sobald du auf einem
hohen User-Level bist, bist du im Prinzip super
Admin und hast Zugriff zu allem.
Aber du hast doch bei Discord explizit so Rollen,
die du unterschiedlich einstellen kannst.
Ja, trotzdem.
In dem Moment, in dem du Admin bist, hast du eine super Rolle.
Okay, Admins sind so ein Sonderding,
aber alle anderen kannst du doch sehr spezifisch verteilen,
wer welche Rechte irgendwie hat. Also es gibt keine
Hierarchie explizit.
Also nur für die Admins.
Genau. Und
Sulib teilt das besser auf und insbesondere,
und das ist für ein Projekt sehr gut,
ist es möglich, dass du halt zum Beispiel private Kanäle
anlegst, die du als Admin anlegen musst.
Also du kannst sagen, diese Kanäle müssen,
also ich muss darüber informiert sein, dass dieser Kanal
existiert, aber
keinen Zugriff drauf kriegst.
Ach, sehr cool. Das geht bei Sulib,
das geht bei Discord witzigerweise nicht, obwohl Discord
eigentlich genau ein sehr gutes Management hat.
Insofern ist Sulib viel Licht, viel
Schatten an der Stelle,
Hat auch eine sehr gute API, mit der man sehr schön Sachen in verschiedene Streams laufen lassen kann.
Zum Beispiel ein Stream, wo jedes Mal, wenn irgendwo was getwittert wird, irgendjemand unseren Twitter-Account erwähnt, dann kommt das in einen Stream, den die Leute halt meistens einfach auf stillgestellt haben.
Keine Notifications und funktioniert alles sehr gut.
Also Sulep würde ich mir auf jeden Fall immer mal wieder anschauen.
Hat auch ganz okaye Clients inzwischen für Mobile.
Läuft natürlich alles auf eine gewappte App irgendwie mit Elektronen und was weiß ich sonst raus.
Aber wenn wir sowas wie Sulib jetzt hier aufzählen,
müssten wir theoretisch auch nochmal ganz kurz über Slack oder sowas wie Microsoft Teams reden, oder?
An sich fällt das, also es gibt ja diese zwei großen Gründe, Chats zu nutzen.
Es gibt die One-to-One-Message, beziehungsweise Gruppenchats,
was auch immer du im direkten Kontakt mit Menschen bleiben möchtest.
Und es gibt diese Workspace-Geschichten.
Genau, ich glaube, wir vermischen das hier so ein bisschen.
weil wir... Das vermischte ich halt auch.
Wir haben jetzt relativ viel über Signal kurz vorher
noch geredet, aber an und für sich
war ja auch bei unserem letzten Gespräch, vor
drei Jahren, also gerade das
Requirement im Raum, was suchen wir für so Community
Management, ne, und da war halt Slack blöd,
weil Slack einfach, da kannst du
immer bloß die Probierversion haben, oder du
hast halt keine, kannst halt
nicht mit deinem eigenen Account kommen,
und sowas wie Signal löst
ja ganz andere Probleme, damit machst du ja keine,
damit machst du ja nicht deinen Firmenchat, du bildest
ja nicht deinen Firmenchat mit Signal ab oder sowas.
oder WhatsApp. Also
Sulib ist jetzt hier so ein Teil,
ja, das ist ganz cool für so Sachen wie
Community oder Firmen,
ähnlich wie Wire, aber dann
müssen wir mal kurz sagen, wie verhält
sich das jetzt zum Beispiel zu dem Platzhirsch?
Sowas wie Slack.
Kann man Slack
noch Leuten empfehlen außerhalb von so
einem Enterprise-Dings oder sagst du eher?
Ja, da bringt der Slack ja nichts.
Wenn ich mir jetzt ein Slack-Works-Aufsätze
kann ich ja nicht mit meiner Familie chatten, es sei denn wir haben
explizit da in Slack-Workspace,
aber das hat auch wieder andere
Nachteile. Aber das ist zum Beispiel, was manche
von den Podcasts machen, ist
sowas wie JS Party,
diese ganzen Change-Log-Podcasts, die sagen
join us in our Slack.
Du hast ja explizit eine Community, das ist halt wieder eine
geschlossene Gruppe,
aber du redest ja nicht aus dem Slack heraus
mit anderen Leuten, die nicht Teil dieser Community sind.
Ja, Slack hat
aber immer noch das große Problem, dass wichtige
Community-Sachen fehlen, also insbesondere die Möglichkeit
andere Leute zu ignorieren. Slack ist halt
nicht für Communities gedacht.
Die halten sich da schnell mal bedeckt.
Die wollten halt immer für Firmen
da sein und die sind dann immer, also gerade
Moderation Features gab es halt nie und die werden sicherlich auch
eine ganze Weile nicht kommen. Du sollst glaube ich auch als
jemand, der bei einer Firma arbeitet,
deine Kollegen nicht unbedingt ignorieren
dürfen, oder?
Es gibt schon Gründe, das zu tun potenziell, aber
die solltest du dann glaube ich auf einer menschlichen Ebene
klären. Das ist halt Slacks Argument. Du machst
Moderation nicht über Slack, sondern Moderation über
deine HR-Abteilung.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, wenn ich jetzt eine 2000-Personen-Firma habe, dann bin ich auch schon fast wieder mehr auf so einem Community-Level, wo manche Leute vielleicht manche Leute doch wirklich einfach nur ignorieren wollen, wenn die nicht im selben Team arbeiten.
Am Ende ist es ein Bot, den du einfach nicht ignorieren willst. Auch das soll ja okay sein. Das muss ja kein Mensch sein.
Oh, ist der Bild schon wieder rot geworden.
Aber wie wenig Slack darüber nachdenkt, hat man ja vor kurzem wieder gesehen.
Die haben ja so ein lustiges Feature eingebaut, dass man, die wollten ja mehr Messenger werden.
Und deswegen konnte man dann beliebige Leute irgendwo anschreiben.
Und zwar konnte man dann sagen, also ich weiß zum Beispiel jetzt einfach aus der Luft gegriffen,
akronomisierbar hat eine Slack-Gruppe und da ist Kilian drin.
Braucht er nicht so, übrigens.
es nicht.
Deswegen greife ich es ja einfach so aus der Luft,
bevor Leute, bevor ich hier
Abuse-Tür und Tor öffne.
Ihr könnt uns übrigens gerne in unserem Matrix-Channel
anschreiben. Sorry, fehlt weiter.
Und dann konnte ich halt
Kilian aus der kalten
ein Bild von meinem Mittelfinger schicken.
Nice.
Schön, dass es nur dein Mittelfinger ist.
Also auf der
Ebene nicht nachgedacht, großes Feature angekündigt
und sofort schreibt jemand auf Twitter drunter,
hey Leute, das ist ein Abuse-Vektor.
Natürlich ist es das.
Und da macht sich Slack halt überhaupt keine Gedanken gefehlt.
Genau, und zwar wirklich null.
Ich habe dann auch noch eine andere Sache,
die auch noch schwierig ist,
gerade für solche Community-Chats,
ist, dass die Nachricht auch war,
wenn man zum Beispiel,
wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel,
ich bin im, so viel kann ich sagen,
ich bin im geschlossenen Chat
der Ethical Thoughts Working Group.
Da kommt man relativ einfach rein.
Man muss einfach mal eine kurze Einsatzbewerbung schreiben.
Das ist schlicht und einfach nur, um die Trolle fernzuhalten.
Aber wenn ich dann jetzt, wenn ich jetzt in diesem Slack drin bin und dann jetzt zum Beispiel Kilian hier anschreiben würde, dann sah die Nachricht auch wirklich aus,
Throne is counting to you on behalf of the ethical source working group.
Also ich konnte auch nicht nur Abuse betreiben aus der Kalten, sondern ich konnte auch noch so tun, als sei ich irgendwie offiziell, irgendwie offizieller Repräsentant dieser Community.
Und das haben die so schnell an vielen, vielen Stellen eingeschränkt.
Dieses Feature ist wirklich komplett kaputt und schwierig.
Ich kann verstehen, warum sie es haben wollen,
weil Slack sich in diese ganz irritierende Ecke gebaut hat,
wo sie Firmen, wo sie Verbindungen zwischen Firmen auch schaffen.
Also es gibt ja irgendwie so geteilte Channels zwischen zwei Firmen.
Das macht total Sinn in diesem gesamten Konzept.
Aber in dem Moment laufen sie plötzlich eben in dieses Problem rein.
Und das kann ich als Unternehmer einfach sagen.
Ich habe regelmäßig schon mal Probleme gehabt, wo Mitarbeiter von anderen Firmen, wo wir Konflikte hatten, wo am Ende C-Level mit C-Level telefonieren musste.
So, hier mal.
Sowas klärt sich normalerweise relativ schnell, aber solche Sachen will man halt nicht irgendwie.
Chat ist ja auch ein sehr persönlicher Raum, kommen wir später auch noch dazu, warum man über viele Sachen lachen könnte, wenn man wollte, aber am besten nicht tun sollte.
jemand, der, also in dem Moment,
in dem ich Zugriff zu Slack habe, habe ich
zu einem One-on-One
Slack, habe ich Zugriff zum
Telefon der anderen Person häufig.
Auch wenn natürlich
jetzt wieder die Gegenbewegung Slack
vom Telefon deinstallieren. Ich habe auch
keine Firmenchats mehr auf meinem Telefon.
Ich kann Slack jetzt deinstallieren vom Handy.
Habe ich ganz vergessen. Nice.
Der macht das natürlich sofort.
Der Lied Freiheit.
Live im Podcast.
um mal wieder auf die UX-Ebene zu kommen.
Die Slack-App auf dem Telefon ist allerdings
ziemlich cool, muss ich sagen, im Vergleich zu
einigen anderen. Die ist auch komplett nativ
und das finde ich, da haben sie sich viel Mühe gegeben.
Das haben sie recht sauber gemacht. Die ist super schön.
Aber wo du gerade sagst,
ja, wir haben jetzt dieses neue coole Feature, haben sie rausgegeben
und dann irgendwie kurz daraus schreibt
jemand, das ist ein Abuse-Vektor, weil sie sich
über solche Sachen keine Gedanken gemacht haben. Das ist genauso
wie Chats
sind erstmal prinzipiell unverschlüsselt,
weil die Leute, die das bauen, erstmal
mit diesem naiven, positiven Mindset
rangehen, wir machen das ja hier
für die Leute und
müssen nicht direkt darüber nachdenken,
wie man das abusen kann.
Das hat die ersten
20 Jahre das Internet so funktioniert
und alle haben ihre Software so gebaut.
Also würde ich da, glaube ich, ein bisschen
Nachsicht haben, wenn ein Ingenieur sagt,
ey geil, das geht, das bauen wir jetzt
und dann erstmal in dieser Bubble
war und dann erst hinterher sagt,
warte mal, klar muss es da einen Prozess
geben, wenn der Firma, die sagt,
cool, fang schon mal an zu bauen, aber
denke währenddessen darüber nach, ob es wirklich eine gute Idee ist.
Das fehlt dann halt. Das ist sinnvoll.
Wenn Leute da einfach anfangen,
was zu bauen, okay, meinetwegen, aber sobald,
bevor es das Licht der Welt abblickt,
das kannst du heutzutage einfach nicht mehr bringen, das Argument,
dass man danach nicht walten lassen soll.
Da musst du nicht mehr darüber gedacht haben, was kannst du damit
für Scheiße anbauen. Auf dem Scale muss das dann natürlich nicht sein.
Ich wollte bloß gerade sagen, dieses Mindset existiert,
weil es hat die ersten 30 Jahre des Internets
genauso funktioniert, bis dann
die Leute plötzlich festgestellt haben, warte mal,
es sind jetzt nicht mehr nur noch die guten
freundlichen Nerds da, sondern auch noch
anderen, wir müssen, glaube ich, ein bisschen
Maßnahmen ergreifen. Was man ihm zugutehalten
darf,
den Slack-Leuten, dass sie ja
an sich Slack eher so aus Versehen entwickelt
haben. Das war ja,
die wollten ja damals, die wollten ein Spiel
mal entwickeln und haben sie aus Versehen Flickr entwickelt.
Und dann wollten sie später nochmal ein Spiel entwickeln
und dann haben sie aus Versehen Slack entwickelt.
Da gibt es einen schönen Podcast
How I Built This, glaube ich, wie
der Typ, der zweimal gepivotet ist in seiner
Karriere mit dieser Firma. Aber aus Versehen
jeweils sehr erfolgreich gewesen ist.
Ich habe da sogar ein bisschen Erfahrung mit. Ich habe eine Weile an Messenger-Apps mitgebaut. Es sind häufig gar nicht die Engineers, bei denen das schiefläuft, weil ganz im Gegenteil, vielen Engineers sind diese Abuse-Faktoren durchaus sehr bewusst, weil die solche Systeme halt und seit Ewigkeiten verwenden.
Aber wenn sie dann sagen, hey Leute, dieses Design ist schwierig, dann kriegen sie aus dem Management zurück, nee, aber das ist jetzt das Design, das wir gemacht haben. Also häufig wird das Design gar nicht von den Leuten gemacht, die das Protokoll entwickeln. Das verwende ich mal kurz als Kick da. Ich sag's mal ganz kurz, über Teams als Chat möchte ich nicht reden und ich glaube, damit ist es abgefrühstückt.
Ich habe Teams ja nie benutzt, ich habe keinen Bedarf zu.
Ich weiß, dass es jetzt ins nächste Windows mit eingebaut ist,
was sicherlich auch sehr viele Android-Tests da.
Ja, aber das nächste Windows kannst du eh auf keinem Computer installieren,
dementsprechend ist das kein Problem.
Als Videocalling finde ich Teams eigentlich inzwischen richtig gut
und vor allem, dass sie einen persistenten Chat über Video,
also man kann Videocall-Serien anmachen,
die einen persistenten Chat haben und so weiter und so fort.
Aus der Sicht finde ich, ich verwende es viel für Trainings,
Ich mache ja inzwischen viel Online-Trainings, aber als Firmenchat ist es jahrelang davon entfernt, dass ich es irgendwie einsetzen würde.
Aber wie es besser geht, deswegen hatte ich vorhin schon mal so vage angedeutet, Matrix hat eine ganze Menge Probleme.
Aber über die letzten drei Jahre, ich hatte ja, wenn man nochmal nachhört, was ich das letzte Mal gesagt habe, hätte ich gesagt, ach, wenn die ein bisschen ihr Design zusammenkriegen würden und ihr Management zusammenkriegen würden, auch auf der Seite von, wie gehen wir eigentlich mit unseren Usern um, dann wäre Matrix viel besser.
und das Fazit aus den letzten drei Jahren,
das ich ziehen muss, ist, das haben sie hinbekommen.
Also es sind immer noch, also ich
könnte ja immer noch eine lange Latte
von Kleinkritik geben,
aber das Gute
ist, die kommt halt irgendwie an
und irgendwie kriegen sie es auch gemanagt
und die
gute Erfahrung, die ich mir wirklich gemacht
habe, in diesen drei
Jahren wurde ja ihr
mozilla.org abgeschaltet
und ich war da ein bisschen
an dem Prozess beteiligt, schlicht und einfach.
Man konnte in dem entsprechenden Channel lurken,
in dem diese Gespräche geführt wurden, was denn als nächstes
kommt. Da war ja auch lange Diskussion,
was es tatsächlich war. Ich glaube, Rocket Chat stand noch mit
zur Debatte, Matrix,
keine Ahnung, ich glaube, es war nie
zur Rede, ob da irgendwie auf Slack migriert wird.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Mattermost noch damals
mit dem Raum stand.
Im Prinzip war da erstmal alles offen, weil
Achso stimmt, anfangs war wirklich, ja ja, es wurde dann irgendwie
auch ein paar Sachen runtergebrochen,
die gute Contender zu schienen
sein, aber ja, du hast recht, es war ja wirklich
offen für, wir suchen irgendwas, was die
der große tolle Nachfolger dafür
wird. Genau, und das war eine ganz
interessante Erfahrung, also erstmal
zu sehen, wie regelmäßig irgendwelche
Leute in diesen, also
Mozilla hat ja sehr klar gesagt, warum sie
von IRC weg müssen,
unter anderem, weil sie 24-7
Moderation Support brauchten,
also allein, weil es ein Spam-Target
war, also IRC Mozilla.org
allein wegen als Spam-Target
war, die Hölle zu betreiben,
weil sie keine Provider mehr gefunden haben,
die einen IRC-Server betreiben.
Und zum anderen, weil halt einfach die ganze Moderationssache
sehr, sehr schwierig war,
Leute persistenten Chat erwarten
und Leute halt zum Beispiel auch so fancy Features
wie Emoji-Reactions oder so erwarten.
Oder Bilder.
Oder History.
Wobei, das kannst du dir immer so Sachen wie IRC-Cloud entfixen.
Also das ist ja am Ende kein Protokollproblem.
Ja, okay, ja.
Die Erfahrung, die ich dabei gemacht habe, war schlicht und einfach, dass die Matrix-Leute am aktivsten waren, aggressiv Feedback einzuholen, also diesen Prozess auch wirklich zu managen, nämlich zu kommen und zu sagen, wir sind hier in einem Evaluierungsprozess, aber das heißt nicht, wir sagen hier einfach mal, hier ist unsere Webseite, guckt doch mal bitte, sondern da hing sofort eine entsprechende Person und zwar aus dem Projekt Leadership in diesem Channel rum.
Matthew war da ja super aktiv, der ist ja da ständig online gewesen.
Ja, aber halt auch wirklich, der hat halt zu einem Problem nicht gesagt, ist kein Problem, sondern hat halt gesagt, ja, schaue ich mir mal an. Und das ist halt eine sehr gute Art und Weise, das zu managen. Und zum Beispiel das Feedback, das wir damals gegeben hatten, da war ich ein bisschen daran beteiligt, war halt eben das, was ich auch in dem Podcast gesagt hatte. Es gibt keine gute Zusammenstellung, wie man eigentlich Moderation macht.
dann haben die einfach gefragt, hast du ein paar gute Beispiele, wie wir das dann machen können?
Und fünf Tage später kommen die mit einer Moderationsdokumentation um die Ecke, wo ich sagen muss,
das ist inzwischen die, auf die ich als Goldstandard verlinke.
Es gibt da immer noch komische Probleme.
Also manche Sachen wurden eine Weile nur als Standarderweiterung unterstützt.
zum Beispiel. Serverweite Bands von Personen
und so weiter ging halt nicht.
Man muss sie aus Channels einzeln sperren.
Aber
das ist dann
halt im Bereich von, das ist
ein Bug und das wird irgendwann in der
Protokollrevision angegangen.
Also da
muss man meiner Meinung nach ein bisschen
Nachsicht walten lassen, wenn
man das Gefühl von dem Projekt halt hat,
die gehen das schon an.
Und
das fand ich,
Und das hat mir sehr, sehr viel Hoffnung für das Projekt gemacht, weil die sehr stark, ich glaube, die eine sehr klare Sicht darauf haben, was sie eigentlich brauchen und was sie eigentlich wollen und eine sehr userzentrierte Sicht.
Sowas wie Mozilla als Kunden für deren IAC-Ersatz zu finden, ist natürlich auch ein Jahrhundertprojekt, was sehr prestigeträchtig ist.
Deswegen kann ich mir vorstellen, dass sie da gesagt haben, kommen hier alle Ressourcen da drauf und wir machen jetzt genau das, was die da brauchen.
Natürlich, aber ich hatte gar nicht den Eindruck, dass sie alle Ressourcen da drauf gemacht haben, sondern sie haben einfach nur die richtige Ressource und ein bisschen dafür gesorgt, dass sie einen Ansprechpunkt hatten.
Es war aber auch super wertvoll, dass sie einfach das als Chance auch gesehen haben für Matrix, um Matrix an sich weiterzuentwickeln. Was fehlt uns denn am Protokoll oder was müssen wir tun, damit wir hier für eine viable Alternative sind? Und das war halt einfach eine super Entscheidung, das so mit anzugehen. Genau das, was du meinst, Flo.
Jetzt würde mich mal interessieren, was sind denn diese Moderation Requirements, die du jetzt als Goldstandard angeben würdest? Bloß mal als kleine Beispiele, was muss man denn heutzutage bieten, um da irgendwie deinen Ansprüchen zu entsprechen?
Also erstmal brauchst du eine Doku dafür, also das war der wichtige Teil. Also es gab zwar irgendwie ein Moderation-API.
Du musst wissen, dass es überhaupt geht quasi.
Genau. Und vor allem wie und mit welchen Situationen.
Und die, also die Guide, die sie geschrieben haben, geht halt vor allem sehr stark ein, sieht es sehr aus der Sicht.
Nicht, hier ist ein Feature, hier banne ich Leute, sondern das möchte ich machen und das ist das, was das Tool anbietet, um das zu ermöglichen.
Und das ist halt die richtige Richtung. Und es gibt ja viele Sachen, also gerade Discord ist da vorne dran.
ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie viel Matrix da jetzt nachimplementiert hat,
zum Beispiel solche Sachen wie Slow-Mode.
Das ist halt, wenn eine große Gruppe von Leuten kommt
und einfach nur einen Channel zuspemmen möchte,
dann wird der Channel halt langsamer
und dann darf man nur noch, was weiß ich,
alle fünf Minuten eine Nachricht posten oder sonst was.
Also, dass man an der Stelle gar nicht hingeht
und jetzt hier irgendwie groß den Bannhammer durch die große Horde schwingt,
sondern die Diskussion verlangsamt und so weiter und so fort.
Also da gibt es eine ganze Menge zu machen,
aber vor allem haben sie halt zum Beispiel auch so eine Sache wie
Handling Unwanted Content as a User.
Was, wenn gerade kein Mod da ist?
Was mache ich als User dann?
Was sind da noch meine Möglichkeiten?
Ich kann, und unter anderem auch,
ich kann darauf negativ reagieren.
Ich kann zum Beispiel negative Emoji-Reactions geben.
Hilft manchmal. Finger runter.
Also wenn es einfach nur jemand ist,
der sich gerade scheiße verhält und so.
Das ist quasi schon eine Art und Weise, darauf zu reagieren und irgendwie den Personen Feedback zu geben, zu sagen, dass das blöd ist oder wie.
Oder sieht man irgendwann als Moderator, oh, ich hatte einen Beitrag, 20 Daumen runter Emoji-Reactions bekommen.
Ist das sowas verlinkt oder ist es einfach bloß, was du gerade meinst, dieses Soziale?
Ja eben, dass Moderation halt auch ein sozialer Akt ist.
Also das wird immer gerne vergessen.
Moderation kann auch sein, direkt einzugreifen und zu sagen, es gibt ja Abuse und es gibt Diskussionen, die einfach nur scheiße laufen.
Und insofern schauen wir beim Rust-Projekt zum Beispiel auch, wer ist ein guter Moderator?
Es sind dann häufig Leute, die halt im besten Sinne des Wortes in Diskussionen moderierend eingreifen, indem sie sagen, hey, das ist ein bisschen doof.
Oder zum Beispiel ganz häufig, gerade in internationalen Kontext, noch einfach, ich glaube, die Person spricht nicht so gut Englisch.
Ich glaube, die hat das nicht so krass gemeint, wie es vielleicht für einen Native English Speaker klingt.
Ist auch immer eine Sache, solche Sachen auch mal zu highlighten.
Oder auch einfach mal als dritte Person zu sagen, ich glaube, ihr redet gerade aneinander vorbei.
Weil das häufig eine Sache ist, die Leute in der Diskussion gar nicht so sehr sehen.
eine Dokumentation zu haben,
die diesen Raum auch einfach aufmacht
und dafür sorgt, dass...
Das könntest du ja vielleicht mal verlinken.
Ich finde das eigentlich ziemlich super,
das überhaupt auf diesem Spektrum zu sehen.
Ich habe nämlich als allererstes immer nur gedacht,
was sind so die technischen Möglichkeiten der Moderation?
Und dann denkt man halt an Banning oder an Slow-Mode
oder an, du kannst zwar Kommentare schreiben,
aber außer dir kann die keiner lesen.
Aber dass man natürlich auch einfach sagt, hier, guck mal, Moderation ist auch einfach so ein zwischenmenschliches Ding und du kannst auch einfach Sachen machen wie Widersprechen oder sowas, dass man darauf hinweist, das ist ja auch vielen Leuten einfach nicht so richtig bewusst.
Gerade bei so großen offenen Chats, wo man einer von vielen ist und das eher eine lose Gruppe von Leuten ist, dann greift ja auch keiner aus dem Nichts ein und er greift unbedingt sofort das Wort und sagt, nee, warte mal, ich glaube, ihr streitet euch unnötigerweise gerade, das muss nicht sein.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die O-Mine einfach nicht da ist und die Leute sich dann einfach raushalten und dann eskaliert das halt weiter.
Wir können es in die Notes packen, ich habe den Link in unserem Vordokument.
eine Sache, die ich noch ein bisschen irritierend finde
an dieser Stelle, also von der Erfahrung her
ist, ich habe
immer noch echte Probleme mit
Element als Client, der ist
irgendwie nicht so
also die Channel-Übersicht
funktioniert für mich nicht
und das ist leider sehr
und eine andere Sache, die mich gerade bei den Moderations-Features
da ganz stark
gemerkt hat, ich hatte es eben kurz
angedeutet, es gibt halt den
Standard-Konform-Modus und dann hat
Synapse, also der Server, den sie
hinten dran implementiert haben, eine Flag für
Synapse Extensions
und zum Beispiel serverweite Bands sind momentan
da nur als Extension drin. Allerdings nach dem
Gespräch, das wir jetzt über Signal hatten, weiß ich nicht
ganz, wie man dieses,
ob das nicht wahrscheinlich eher die
Sache ist, die ich mehr
bevorzuge, dass sie halt hingehen und sagen, in Synapse
bauen wir das schon mal ein. Es ist
hinter einer Feature-Flag, also wir haben einen standardkonformen
Modus und wir haben einen Modus mit Erweiterungen
und da
probieren wir solche Sachen schon mal aus.
Element, also deren
Webfrontend passt halt auch darauf auf,
ob Synems gerade im
Standardkonformen Modus läuft oder nicht.
So ein bisschen hat man das ja aktuell schon mit
dem Spaces Feature, was
hier zum Beispiel, also dieses
neue Community Feature, was sie jetzt neu gebaut haben,
was du ja haben willst, um bestimmte Sachen
zu gruppieren, dass du sagen kannst, die Räume
hier gehören irgendwie zueinander,
was früher alles ein bisschen eklig war,
aber dass du quasi jetzt hier dein
Slack beziehungsweise deine Community halt
in Matrix besser abbilden kannst,
Das ist ja aktuell so in Synapse mit implementiert,
dass du, das meiste davon macht der Client,
das macht Element, aber zum Beispiel das Listing,
ob du, was in einem Space an Räumen existiert,
das ging nur, wenn du ein aktuelles Synapse auch umlaufen hast.
Und das ist das weiße Element auch damit umzugehen
und konnte dir das eben anzeigen.
Aber man merkt schon, dass du jetzt bereits
in dieser Federation
versus Standard versus Features
Hölle angekommen sind, auf eine gewisse Art
und Weise. Du hast gerade gemeint,
es ist eigentlich ganz okay, dass die das irgendwie so als
Synapse-spezifisches
Flag anmachen.
Das musst du wahrscheinlich machen, um sowas
irgendwie anzutesten und zu schauen,
wie es so funktioniert, bevor du es irgendwie in den Standard
erheben kannst. So machen das ja
viele andere Plattformen auch.
In den Browsern gibt es Feature-Flags für bestimmte
Sachen, in Rust gibt es Feature-Flags
und hier musst du sowas machen, bevor du
da irgendwie hingehst und sagst, ich schreibe das jetzt in den
Standard rein, warte, bis das alle implementiert haben
und dann sehen wir erst, wie es funktioniert, sondern
du musst ja wahrscheinlich ein bisschen so
in Vorleistung gehen, bevor du das
zu einem stabilen Standard
erheben kannst.
Aber auf die gleiche Art und Weise merkst du halt auch,
okay, das ist jetzt ein Feature. Das geht
halt nicht überall.
Kean hatte die
Akronomisierbar-Community aufgemacht
mit diesem neuen Feature und ich hatte,
wir hatten da auch Leute reingezogen
in Sachen.
ich hatte das glaube ich angefangen für
ein anderes Projekt und da haben sich Leute erstmal
beschwert, also was du auch immer hier gerade gemacht hast
ich verstehe es nicht, weil auf meinem
Mobile Client wird es
nicht unterstützt und das sieht jetzt hier gerade komisch aus
Das hast du bei Matrix ja schon quasi immer
also was heißt schon immer
ich habe ja lange versucht
beziehungsweise noch nicht aufgehört damit
einen Matrix Client zu implementieren
und der kann halt viele Features nicht
und da musst du halt mit umgehen, dass du halt
bestimmte Message Types nicht rendern kannst
dass du halt irgendwie
die Spaces nicht aktuell
nicht unterstützt oder dass sonst was
nicht da ist, aber jeder
Client hat halt bei so einem komplexen Protokoll
immer damit zu kämpfen, dass du nur ein Subset
der Features implementierst, was
teilweise Designziel sein kann, was teilweise
einfach nur sein kann, dass du der Rest work in progress
ist und du nicht hinterhergekommen bist.
Es ist halt immer eine Frage, wie du
das abbildest, dass da bestimmte Sachen nicht funktionieren.
Ich habe
mit beiden Communities
also
Communities war ja ein Feature in Synapse und Matrix.
Mit beiden Varianten ein Problem.
Das erste Communities-Feature haben wir immer nicht verwendet.
Wir haben immer das Feedback bekommen,
wir haben ja einen unifizierten Matrix-Server für Rust-Leute,
Rust-Chat.
Und da haben die Leute immer gefragt,
wenn ihr Konferenzen drauflaufen lässt,
warum packt ihr die nicht alle in der Community?
Der Grund war, Communities waren so kaputt,
dass der Server dann zwischendurch komplett abgestürzt ist.
versucht hat, auf sie zuzugreifen.
Und wenn man
gefragt hat, wann wird denn das endlich gefixt, kam immer
zurück, naja, wir schaffen das Feature eh ab, das bleibt
jetzt so. Also eine ganze Weile einfach
in diesem komischen Limbo-Zustand rumgehangen, das stimmt.
Ja, es war einfach super
kaputt und das ist halt
hässlich, wenn du ein Feature hast im Client, wo du halt
so, ne, es ist halt drin
und dann klickst du halt lustig dir so eine Community
zusammen und plötzlich funktioniert gar nichts mehr und du musst
bei deinem Admin anrufen, der Admin sagt, ich finde
hier irgendwie komische Queries im Log
und irgendwie schlagen Queries fehl.
ich habe das Gefühl, dass sie mit Spaces
ein bisschen übers Ziel rausgeschossen
sind, weil wenn man sich den Ankündigungs-
Blogpost von Spaces anschaut,
dann steckt da
drin, oh, wir sind jetzt
full Computer Science gegangen,
eigentlich sind Spaces auch nur Räume,
die Räume enthalten, die könnten
noch besondere andere Räume mit anderen
Properties enthalten, also alles ist eigentlich
ein Raum und eigentlich sind Räume, am Ende hat
der Twitter-Account von Matrix
Eigentlich sind Räume ja nur Nachrichtenfilter sozusagen.
Und ich bin mal sehr gespannt, was da passiert und wie da der Wildwuchs läuft.
Auf der anderen Seite finde ich, ich bin mal gespannt, wie es funktioniert.
Es ist, glaube ich, nämlich gar nicht so uninteressant, an der Stelle auch einfach zu sagen,
wir sind ein Nachrichtenprotokoll und Nachrichten sind heutzutage viel, viel mehr als nur Text.
Also im Prinzip könnte man, ich habe mich am Freitag unterhalten mit demjenigen, der die Online-Plattform fürs Worstfest implementiert und hat gesagt, eigentlich könnten wir die Video-Playouts als Matrix-Raum implementieren.
Mache ich gerade nicht, aber es ginge theoretisch.
Fände ich gar nicht so uncool.
Und an der Stelle muss ich auch ehrlich sagen, es gibt schon noch einen Grund, warum wir für unsere Konferenzen auf Matrix setzen.
weil es das einzige ist, wo wir überhaupt irgendwie Integration reinbauen können und irgendwie eine gewisse Anzahl von Freiheit haben und was auch ein professionelles Produkt mit all seinen Vor- und Nachteilen ist. Also es geht halt manchmal nicht in die Richtung, in die wir wollen.
Wenn halt die Leute bei Matrix sagen, wir fixen die Communities jetzt nicht, dann sind wir halt ein halbes Jahr unterwegs mit, wir vertaggen die Räume halt mit einem Namen und du musst die alle einzeln joinen und es gibt irgendwo auf der Webseite kannst du Join All Rooms klicken und dann gehst du.
Aber man kann sich da, also wir haben überhaupt die.
Ja, und ich hatte es ja in dem Podcast über Konferenzen gesagt, es ist ein riesiges Problem für Online-Konferenzen, dass wir keine Freiheiten haben, unsere Sachen selbst zu fixen. Und ja, das Ding ist kaputt, aber B, die Plattform bietet uns die Möglichkeit, innerhalb von einer Stunde einen Hack außenrum zu implementieren.
Für die erste Konferenz, als wir es festgestellt haben, war es wortwörtlich, ich habe ein Skript geschrieben, das einfach diese ganzen Räume angelegt hat, zack, zack, zack, zweimal gegen das Rate Limit gelaufen ist. Das ist dann auch immer schon mal gut, wenn der Server in der Standardeinstellung, die man laufen lässt, ein Rate Limit hat. Das gibt ein schönes, warmes Gefühl.
Insofern ist es ein Vorteil von Matrix, dass es einfach bloß ein HTTP-basiertes Protokoll ist, weil man eben schnell für ein Minimal-Feature und ein Client, der nur das kann, bauen kannst quasi.
Ja, genau.
Du könntest es theoretisch auch als IoT-Message-Broker nutzen.
Also Matrix, das haben sie anfangs immer so schön gesagt,
Chat ist einfach nur quasi ein Nebenfeature von dem, was wir hier gebaut haben.
Vielleicht so das Hauptfeature, wo das Augenmerk draufliegt,
aber nicht sagt, dass du Matrix für Chat nehmen musst.
Also es ist unglaublich vielseitig.
Aber für Chat ist es hauptsächlich geeignet, weil für IoT ist es zu langsam, oder?
Für alles andere ist es doch...
Ja, aber die Geschwindigkeitsprobleme sind ja nicht im Protokoll verankert.
Das war ja eher so, weil Synapse unglaublich unperformant damals lief und gerade wenn du über Federation-Grenzen hinweg sprechen wolltest, hast du dann mehrere Synapses, die miteinander gesprochen haben.
Aber die Tatsache, dass sie auch, ich sehe es gerade an deiner Seitenleiste da auf Matrix.org, dieses Low-Bandwidth-Matrix, das war ja auch, was sie auf der Vostemp vor ein paar Jahren mit einem Talk gehalten hatten,
dass du unglaublich kleine Nachrichten umherschicken kannst
und da auch Spaß einfach mit hatten,
dass auch HTTP halt nicht gegeben sein muss,
sondern du auch über andere Sachen sprechen kannst.
Ich fand es einfach schön, dass sie sich die Freiheiten lassen.
Es gibt natürlich, es macht viele Dinge wieder komplexer,
gerade auch den Chat-Use-Case,
aber es ist an sich unglaublich vielseitig und unglaublich frei,
weil du kannst einfach mal was skripten.
Das ist überhaupt kein Thema.
Du kannst einfach mal andere Sachen damit machen.
Manche Sachen laufen nicht so gut,
aber es ist frei und sowas, kannst du halt über Slack jetzt nicht bringen.
Ich finde, was sie immer mehr machen, und das finde ich sehr gut,
ist, dass sie ein bisschen dieses Ökosystem auch ein bisschen managen,
indem sie dann halt einfach, indem sie sagen,
wir bieten halt eine Standardimplementierung von Server an
und wir bieten eine professionelle Standardimplementierung vom Client an,
also damit sie halt nicht in die XMPP-Falle laufen.
Es gibt halt für jedes Betriebssystem und für jede Plattform
gibt es einen supporteden Client und der wird halt
vom Projekt auch gleich mit ausgeliefert
und zweitens, dass sie, so langsam
habe ich so den Eindruck, beginnen für
bestimmte Use Cases Bibliotheken
zu schreiben, wo man dann halt
sagen kann, ich möchte halt,
wenn die Leute halt auf
meiner Glühbirne chatten wollen,
dann nehme ich halt
Lipmatrix Lightbulb
und das ist die Nachricht für meine Glühbirne drauf.
Also
das lässt sich
an der Stelle schon managen
und ich denke, sie sind deswegen auf einem guten Weg
und vor allem sind sie halt nicht in die Falle gelaufen,
die ich damals vor drei Jahren noch als Angst hatte,
dass sie halt sagen, ja, wir haben hier ein Protokoll geschrieben,
macht was draus und anstatt dass,
die haben ja auch einige Mozilla-Leute,
nachdem Mozilla ein paar Leute entlassen hat letztes Jahr,
angeheuert, die haben halt ein Produktmanagement.
So im guten Sinne.
Und ja, die Channelbar auf der linken Seite,
die will ich immer noch bitte einmal neu geschrieben haben.
Aber ich bin mir relativ sicher,
dass das irgendwann dann auch passieren wird.
Die Mikro-Typo, wie man so schön sagt,
also da finde ich es,
also Discord meiner Meinung nach hat immer noch den schönsten Klein
für meinen Hacker-Face sozusagen,
also mit kleiner Typo, aber trotzdem gut lesbar.
Matrix hat das noch nicht ganz,
aber die kommen da irgendwann an.
Und die Freiheit, in diesem System zu integrieren,
das ist eine sehr gute Sache,
weil das halt heißt,
ich muss nicht unbedingt wegwechseln,
wenn ich unbedingt,
wenn ich irgendwie ein bestimmtes Feature brauche.
Und insofern funktionieren die da für uns doch recht gut.
Und nachdem sie jetzt ihre Federation
ein bisschen schneller hinbekommen haben,
also ich finde halt immer noch,
das Federation-Feature führt zu Problemen,
wie zum Beispiel allen Leuten immer erklären muss,
naja, du bist jetzt aber auf dem Rust-Chat-Account
mit deinem Account von Matrix.org
und deswegen verhält sich das ein bisschen anders.
Auf der anderen Seite muss ich sagen,
ich habe jetzt gestern mal aus einer Laune raus
Rust-Chat an Libera-Chat gehängt,
weil ich mal meinen Umzug von Freenode wegmachen muss.
Beziehungsweise, ich muss da ja nicht umziehen.
Das Haus haben sie abgerissen.
Da gibt es nichts mehr zum Mitnehmen.
Und das andere, um auch die Brücke zu schlagen, Matrix Org hat halt ein, inzwischen doch, sie haben die Foundation gegründet, sie haben sich Gelder gesucht, zum Beispiel vom französischen Staat und so weiter und so fort, sie haben sich da irgendwie durchfinanziert gekriegt.
Vergiss nicht die Bundeswehr, die mittlerweile auch Matrix nutzen.
Ja gut, aber...
Scheißegal, was die Bundeswehr da macht.
Ich glaube, die nutzen das, aber ich weiß nicht, ob bei der Bundeswehr Geld zu holen ist.
Nice.
Aber ich finde diesen Punkt von dir eigentlich ganz spannend, dass man nicht einfach nur sagt, hier ist ein Protokoll, ist alles gut dokumentiert, ihr seid alle selbstständig erwachsene Softwareentwickler, macht was draus.
sondern dass es dann eine Beispielimplementierung gibt,
die von den Hauptorganisatoren gemacht wird.
Weil das ist eigentlich das Wichtigste, was du machen kannst,
dass du sagst, hier zieht euch einfach das Update und dann geht's.
Weil dann ist es auch egal, vielleicht ist es nicht ganz so wichtig,
dass es genau über HTTP geht.
Vielleicht können wir auch das morgen ändern.
Hauptsache, die Libraries bleiben kompatibel miteinander,
weil wir irgendwie mehrere Sachen abbilden.
Das ist, glaube ich, an manchen Stellen wichtiger.
Das Protokoll muss natürlich auch gut dokumentiert sein,
damit da Leute auch eine Gegenimplementierung bilden können,
aber das Problem läuft dann halt immer darauf hinaus,
dass du unterschiedliche Subsets von dem Protokoll nur implementierst,
wenn du es nicht vollständig machst.
Und wenn du sagst, hier, wir möchten jetzt ein neues Feature haben,
dann musst du halt auch in Vorleistung gehen und sagen,
wir bauen das jetzt hier schon mal ein, hier gibt es das schon.
Die Clients können es dementsprechend nach dem Update automatisch
und wir sind nicht davon abhängig, dass wir sagen,
Ja, schön wäre es, wenn es irgendwer implementiert würde,
aber es macht einfach keiner.
Das ist echt fair.
Ja, also ich finde, sie gehen da an vielen Stellen in die richtige Richtung
und verstehen vor allem, dass die Technik und das soziale System
da draufgearbeitet sind.
Es hat immer noch so ein paar Nerd-Tishes.
Eine Sache, die ich sehr lustig fand,
ich habe Riot lange nicht verwendet.
Ich habe es ganz am Anfang ausprobiert
und habe es natürlich zuerst mal zu irseemozilla.org gebridged.
Und als dann diese Sache kam,
habe ich
mit dem Umstieg als erstes mal wieder
Riot ausgepackt und habe dabei festgestellt,
dass sie, dass im Rust-Channel
zwischendurch
ich glaube
eine Viertelmillion
Nachrichten durchgelaufen sind.
Stark. Und das Interface
konnte damit umgehen. Da stand dann
0.4
Million.
Schön, dass das
dann nicht irgendein Formatfehler ist, sondern
dass dann wirklich angezeigt wird.
Was da eine Viertelmillion Nachrichten
wird. Ich hatte das kommentiert und dann meinte
der Entwickler dazu,
oh ja, ich dachte damals, das sei ein bisschen exzessiv,
aber jetzt bin ich doch ganz froh, dass ich den kann.
Aber das spricht auch für eine gewisse
Sauberkeit.
Ich meine, ich habe jetzt ein bisschen über das visuelle Design
und so weiter gemaut.
Es sind ja die gleichen Sachen, die wir Signal vorgeworfen haben
übrigens vor ein paar Minuten,
dass an der UI einfach nicht genug
gemacht wird.
An der UI wurde ja
gearbeitet. Also als Riot zu Element wurde,
wurde ja schon auch einmal
voll durchgearbeitet an der Stelle.
Aber ich möchte ja hier mal auch drauf hinweisen,
Element ist nicht der einzige
Matrix-Klein. Es ist der fully-featured
Matrix-Klein. Es ist so quasi die
volle Matrix-Experience,
weil du ja auch durch die Dev-Tools in Element die Möglichkeit
hast, unformatierte
Random-Custom-Events zu verschicken in Räumen,
was teilweise auch sehr cool sein kann.
Aber es ist nicht der einzige,
das ist nicht der only kid on the block.
Es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Matrix-Kleinern mittlerweile,
die teilweise auch sehr schick, teilweise sehr funktional
sind. Für den Desktop.
Ja, auch da kann man
Dinge machen. Und das
sage ich jetzt nicht nur als eine Person, die jetzt
ganz offiziell
auch dafür bezahlt wird, an der Mach-E-S-Klein zu
arbeiten, aber es ist
gerade die Möglichkeit, die wir da eben
haben, dadurch, dass das
funktioniert, ist großartig.
Da kriegst du immer mehr und mehr tolle
Dinge.
Ja,
ich meine,
Das ist ja auch gut.
Man hat natürlich immer das Problem als Third-Party-Entwickler,
dass man dem Hauptprojekt immer ein bisschen hinterherläuft.
Muss man auch einfach.
Oder man ist am Ende an der Entwicklung auch selbst direkt beteiligt
und ist dann irgendwie an der Protokoll-Schnallisierung mit dabei.
Aber das Problem wird nicht weggehen.
Und wenigstens diskutieren sie es auch nicht weg.
Nee, das stimmt.
Und noch ganz kurz.
Element und Send-Ups sind halt auch keine Beispiel-Implementierungen,
sondern halt wirkliche volle Referenz-Implementierungen,
die auch dazu da sind, von User genutzt zu werden.
Und ich glaube, das ist ein Problem,
in das XMPP so ein bisschen gelaufen ist,
dass es zwar immer Referenz-Implementierungen gab,
aber man sich dann immer auf andere Leute verlassen hat,
dass sie es hoffentlich auch implementieren.
Und da merke ich sehr stark, dass Matrix das erkannt hat.
und auf der anderen Seite auch,
auch wenn ich immer über Bridging so ein bisschen lache,
also man kann ja alles bridgen,
dass Bridging für Matrix halt ein First-Class-Use-Case ist,
habe ich so den Eindruck.
Ja, es war von Anfang an Thema,
dass man halt diesen Network-Effekt auch quasi so ein bisschen umgehen kann,
indem man Matrix für sich selber nutzt
und halt die anderen Netzwerke mit reinbridgt,
dass ich auf Matrix sitzen kann.
Also ich nutze das sehr gerne auch jenseits von den ganzen anderen Bridges.
und zum Beispiel den Chat vom
lokalen Computer Club, vom C3D2
mitzulesen. Da bin ich
mehr so Beisitzer, also nicht Beisitzer,
das ist halt falscher Offizier, da bin ich mehr so
Mitleser einfach, aber der ist halt
offiziell in einem Jabber irgendwo
am Laufen und der ist gebridged
zu IRC und zu Matrix und das ist einfach
schön, dass ich da
die Möglichkeit habe, dass
Ich finde es extrem gut, dass ich da nicht
Clients offen haben muss, insofern
finde ich das
sehr angenehm.
Sie schauen mal nicht vor den großen
Brettern zurück, sage ich mal so.
Ja, genau.
Insofern ist
wirklich über die letzten drei Jahre,
muss ich sagen, dass meine Sicht von Matrix
von, ich
habe ein paar Bauchschmerzen zu
ja, es wird.
Es wird langsam.
Es wird und sie machen die richtigen Moves
und sie holen sich das richtige Feedback.
Weil sie halt vor allem mit Usern reden.
Ganz viel mit Usern reden.
Auf jeden Fall. Aber jetzt, wo wir vorhin schon die kurze Unterscheidung
hatten zwischen Chats für
Communities und Chats für, sagen wir mal
grob gesehen für DMs und
also Direktnachrichten zu anderen Leuten.
Matrix deckt halt beides ganz gut ab.
Und das kann es halt vor allem gerade dadurch,
dass es Federation Support gibt.
Und ich kann bei Matrix, also ich bin
Matrix mittlerweile als den Hauptmessenger für
alles. Wir schreiben Direktnachrichten
über Matrix. Obwohl ich den Eindruck habe, dass ich
manchmal Nachrichten auf anderen Kanälen schicken muss, damit
du es überhaupt merkst. Ja, die Notifications
von Element sind nicht immer,
irgendwie landen die manchmal nicht auf meiner Uhr, habe ich das Gefühl,
dann kriege ich die nicht mit.
Das ist eine kleine Unsauberheit,
aber das ist ein klein Problem von
Element. Also ich
bin einfach so ein bisschen gebranntes Kind, weil
ich einen Matrix-Org-Account hatte
und das war so langsam,
dass ich dann irgendwann,
seitdem ist bei mir einfach so noch
im Hinterkopf, Matrix ist
einfach langsam. Das hat man
dieses Gefühl dazu.
Es bleibt irgendwie auch die Tatsache, dass
alles irgendwie erstmal
wie so ein Git-Repository auf allen Servern
breitgeschmiert wird, wenn ich auf einem anderen Home-Server bin
als jemand anders. Das ist halt nicht...
Ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass Matrix
sonderlich schnell ist, wenn ich nicht auf derselben Kiste
bin wie die anderen.
Das ist halt eine Frage...
Das merkst du, wenn du auf einem performanteren
Home-Server unterwegs bist, dass es halt wirklich
damals ein Matrix-Org-Problem war.
Mittlerweile hat sich da auch viel getan. Die haben sehr viel
Synapse rumgeschraubt, um da auch die Performance
zu optimieren, gerade weil halt
zigtausend Leute auf Matrix.org unterwegs
sind. Das ist ja genau dieses Jabber-CCC.de
Problem, wo der CCC damals
einen Jabber-Server erstellt hat, damit man mehr dezentral
Server verteilen konnte. Und plötzlich waren
alle dutzend gegangen. Und dann haben sie die Registration wieder zugemacht.
Das war jetzt aber nicht die Idee, dass ihr alle
hierher kommt. Wir wollten nur einen weiteren Server,
nicht den Server haben.
Ja, aber das ist immer das, was die Leute
bei Federation
mitdenken.
Oh, es gibt jetzt Federation, das heißt
Es gibt irgendwie, jetzt muss ich mich auch noch kümmern,
wo ich mir meinen Matrix-Account klicke.
Das muss ich bei Signal und bei WhatsApp nicht.
Da mache ich mir einfach meinen WhatsApp-Account fertig.
Und das ist manchmal noch ein bisschen zu schwierig,
so für den Einsteiger gerade.
Nur sind wir jetzt gerade irgendwie auf einem gemeinsamen,
ich finde es gut, wenn sich irgendjemand hinstellt und sagt,
ich hoste jetzt meinen eigenen Homeserver
und da können meinetwegen noch ein paar andere Leute mit drauf.
Ich finde es auch super, wenn es zum Beispiel heißt,
sowas wie die Universität in der Stadt hostet sowas
und dann kann jeder als Student mit drauf
oder beziehungsweise jeder, der mal Student war,
könnte da prinzipiell mit drauf,
weil ob das nur 35.000 oder 100.000 sind,
macht das auch keinen großen Unterschied.
Aber es wird sich definitiv nicht,
und das haben viele bei Federation irgendwie immer so mit angesprochen,
es wird sich nicht jeder zu Hause so einen Matrix-Server
selber hosten und hinstellen und die Zeit investieren,
um das zu machen.
Ja, ich finde es auch super toll,
dass gerade die, wenn wir schon bei Universitäten sind,
die TU Dresden sich da voll dahinter geschmissen hat
und zum einen
Matrix-Server hosted für
alle Uni-Angehörigen, aber zum anderen
auch die Probleme,
die halt entdeckt werden, die halt noch
im Weg stehen, um das auch für digitale Lehre zu nutzen
und so weiter, mitfinanziert
die Entwicklung auf Seiten der
Matrix Foundation. Und das finde ich einfach
sehr toll. Und die TU Dresden
macht sich da auch echt stark, die waren auch schon öfter mit
in This Week in Matrix mit erwähnt,
das zu verbreiten, auch
zu anderen Unis hierzulande. Und
das finde ich einfach sehr angenehm,
den Bezug hier zu
der Uni noch mit haben und die sich da auch
echt stark macht.
Also
ich habe jetzt
so ein bisschen
sehr gegen Federation geschossen. Ich finde
Federation auf einer Community
Ebene sehr interessant, weil es gerade eben
wichtige Community
Funktionen erst ermöglicht.
Also auf einer politischen Ebene finde ich
Federation total interessant, weil es eben die Möglichkeit
gibt zu sagen, ich vertraue den Leuten, die
meinen Server laufen lassen. Ich glaube,
deswegen war java.ccc.de auch so erfolgreich,
weil die Leute halt sagen, das ist der Java-Server
vom CCC.
Die werden meine Daten nicht verkaufen.
Und deswegen
fand ich es auch so ein bisschen schade, dass sie da im Prinzip so ein bisschen
User-Beleidigung
betrieben haben und
deswegen
betreiben wir ja auch Rust-Chat
einfach als die Plattform, wo wir mit unserem
Chat-Kram für
Rust-Sachen halt machen können, was
wir wollen, ohne da jetzt
die armen Leute in Frankreich mit unseren
also wenn ich da
fünfmal in mein Rate Limit hin laufe, dann
schreibe ich halt dem Admin schnell eine E-Mail und sage
ich war das.
Diese Sachen kleiner zu ziehen hat große
Vorteile, auch einfach bessere Kontaktpunkte
und so weiter.
Die Leute kennen sich, das ist immer sehr gut, wenn man die Leute,
die den Support machen, kennt
auf eine gewisse Art und Weise
Vertrauen hat und zum anderen, dass
man halt auch sagen kann, naja
natürlich können die Nazis jetzt
ihren Matrix oder Mastodon betreiben
oder sonst was. Bei Mastodon
gibt es ja das Thema auch, aber wir
na gut,
Mastodon jetzt einfach das Federation-Beispiel,
aber wir können halt einfach sagen, mit denen federaten wir nicht.
Ja. Also gerade die
Möglichkeit halt zu sagen, wir federaten
mit bestimmten Gruppen
auch nicht. Das ist auch immer so ein witziges Problem
gerade bei der Federation. Das hatte
ich gemerkt, als der TU-Server
existiert hatte, der FSR-Server
existiert hatte plötzlich und
beide noch nicht ganz offene Federation hatten,
aber mit manchen Servern eben schon, unter anderem
mit dem kleinen, auf dem ich war.
Und
transitive Federation,
ist so ein Ding, was ich bei Matrix noch nicht ganz verstehe,
wie das genau gehandhabt wird. Wenn
Server A mit Server B spricht, aber Server A
nicht mit Server C, aber B und C
sprechen miteinander, dann kriegen A und C
ja trotzdem über B irgendwie Nachrichten
hin, aber direkte Kommunikation
zum Beispiel für das Abrufen von
den MXC-URLs, von Ressourcen,
Bilder, ein Avatar und so weiter existiert da nicht.
Aber Nachrichten fließen durch,
weil es irgendwie alles ein bisschen weird und tricky ist.
Aber das ist dann auch wieder einer der Edge-Cases
von Federation. Das heißt, wenn ich
jetzt irgendwie als lokaler
AfD,
nee, warte, das muss ich anders anfangen, wenn jetzt so ein lokaler
AfDler irgendwie sich bei dem
Parler Matrix anmeldet
und dann
in der TU Dresden rumrenten möchte
und die TU Dresden sagt, wir
federaten jetzt nicht mehr
mit Parler.matrix,
dann könnten
die trotzdem noch
irgendwie über andere Sachen in anderen Channels
auf die gleichen...
Wie gesagt, Nachrichten können transitiv durch andere
Server durchfließen und das ist ein bisschen
tricky. Also Federation wirft dich schon vor
sehr komische Probleme, die
sicherlich nicht einfach zu lösen sind.
Das ist diese Einstellung, die du bei deinem
Mail-Server, wenn du den selber einrichtest, als
allererstes ausmachen musst, dass du
E-Mails von anderen Mail-Servern weitergibst.
Stimmt, das ist ja auch so, was Mail eigentlich kann.
Das ist genau das, was Mail irgendwie
von Anfang an gemacht hat und dann musstest du das
aber, wenn du das einrichtest, sofort ausmachen,
damit du irgendwie nicht so aus Spermschleuder wirst und
irgendwie von allen Leuten geblockt wirst.
Ich sehe das Problem nicht so ganz.
Also eigentlich,
das, was du beschrieben hast, klingt
aus einer,
klingt für mich ein bisschen nach
Works as Intended, weil das ist ja ein Problem,
das Mastodon hat,
weil Mastodon ja
lustig zum Beispiel Bilder weiterleitet.
So, und Bilder können halt zum Beispiel
sehr schnell illegal sein,
Im Sinne von, mein Server darf die gar nicht ausliefern,
sonst kommt die Polizei vorbei.
Oder sie können Rechteinhabern gehören zum Beispiel.
Das ist ein schwieriges Management.
Und an der Stelle finde ich eigentlich,
die Nachricht wird leitergeleitet,
aber die Medien nicht geladen.
Erst mal einen ganz guten Zwischenpunkt.
Vielleicht ist das tatsächlich enthanded.
Ja, es kann sein.
Eventuell sollte das der Client dann an der Stelle besser abfangen
und sagen, das ist übrigens Medien,
von einem von uns nicht freigeschalteten Server
ausgeliefert werden. Also gerade wenn es
um Medien geht, wäre ich an solchen Stellen sehr, sehr
vorsichtig als
Serverbetreiber und würde eigentlich eher gerne
allow-listen,
wer denn Medien zu mir
pushen darf. Also das ist ja ein großes Problem von Federation,
eigentlich dieses ungefilterte
Pushen. Ja, stimmt.
Auf der anderen Seite diese Verbindungen
aufzubauen, finde ich
überhaupt nicht schlecht. Also es gibt einem
erstmal die Möglichkeit, überhaupt auf einer
softwaretechnischen Ebene über solche Sachen überhaupt zu
reden. Und
als Community eben zu managen,
also ich kenne Mastodon-Server
von Leuten, ich meine, kann man
ja drüber reden, aber es ist ja
Public, AFIRE,
der Twitter verlassen hat,
weil er keine
BDSM-Bilder auf Twitter
posten darf, aber das für ihn halt ein wichtiger
Teil von Queer-Repräsentation ist, hat ein Mastodon-Server,
wo er halt sagt, hier
ist das okay.
Insofern ist die Möglichkeit,
den einfach selbst zu betreiben
Und zu sagen, wer hier joint, der weiß, was auf diesem Server hier rumgeschickt wird. So steht ja auch groß drin, es steht groß in den Serverregeln und die Möglichkeit überhaupt solche Spaces zu bauen. Twitter hat ja das Problem, dass Twitter im Prinzip die Moderationsregeln machen muss, die global für alle Menschen gelten.
Und die einzige Regel, die sie da haben, ist,
this post contains potentially sensitive pictures.
Media oder sowas.
Während ich in solchen Sachen dann halt eben sagen kann,
das ist ein Matrix, das ist ein Matrix-Server
und eine Matrix-Community, wo bestimmte Themen okay sind
und wo es aber halt auch komplett abgeschlossen ist.
Wenn Leute aber diesen Server nutzen wollen,
um zum Beispiel mit Leuten außerhalb zu reden,
dann können sie das tun mit ihrem Ad-Sonstwas-Doppelpunkt-Sonstwas-Tag.
Also sie können das halt eben auch als Nachrichtenplattform nutzen.
Aber es gibt einem ein viel besseres Scoping,
als dass wir schmeißen das alles im Prinzip in eine globale Datenbank.
Und deswegen finde ich halt gerade,
also was Federation halt auch ermöglicht,
ist halt gerade die Nicht-Föderation.
Auch zu sagen, hier ist keine Datenbank.
Das ist jetzt eine kleine
Gated Community für uns,
wo unsere Regeln gelten.
Ja, Gated Community ist so ein verbranntes Wort.
Nee, Gated Community ist unser kleines gallisches Dorf.
Ja,
es ist halt ein Raum. Also ich kann jetzt halt
Räume bilden.
Im Sinne von,
hier gelten andere
Community-Regeln.
Folgtitel.
Bildet Räume.
Ja, das ist schwierig.
Aber?
Wir müssen noch kurz über Orte reden,
wo wir nicht mehr hingehen können.
Was meint ihr damit?
Was ist denn jetzt eigentlich bei
Threenode passiert?
Was ist denn jetzt eigentlich bei Threenode passiert?
Ich glaube, das kann Flo
als am meisten Betroffener hier
am besten zusammenfassen, das ganze Drama
darum. Ich bin da überhaupt nicht
betroffen.
Du warst doch noch verwendet,
mit einer Person
DMs auszutauschen und das
war es.
Ich hab da früher auf Freenode gerne mit aktiv.
Also Freenode war ja generell so eine schöne
GoStar-IRC-Server,
wo quasi alle Communities
waren, also wirklich Räume für literally alles.
Das war der IRC-Server.
Ich hab immer gedacht, IRC
ist nur auf Freenode.
Das hat sich auch jemand
gedacht, ja. Also
was wo passiert ist,
ich hab's mal ein bisschen versucht zusammen zu
stöpseln.
Das ist relativ schwierig aus Tweets
und verschiedenen Gists die Leute
zusammengeschrieben habe, überhaupt rauszufinden, was
wirklich passiert ist. Was wohl passiert ist,
ist das Freenode,
also das große, offene FOSS-Netzwerk,
wo jedes FOSS-Projekt
zumindest mal einen inoffiziellen
Channel hat, also
Rust hatte da einen Channel mit 1500
Leuten, auch wenn wir da offiziell nie
unterwegs waren.
Ja, plötzlich seine
Policies geändert hat.
Und woran das wohl lag, ist, dass Freenode rechtlich einer Firma namens Freenode Limited gehört hat, die einem der Betreiber gehört hat, und zwar irgendwie so im Vertrauen, so, ja, also Markenrechte und Server und so weiter liegen alle hier.
Und einer der Co-Besitzer dieser Firma, die wohl übernommen hat von dieser Person, wenn ich das jetzt richtig gesehen habe, Andrew Lee, wohl alles legal und dann gesagt hat, so, jetzt machen wir hier mal, so, ich hätte gerne, dass alles hier anders läuft.
Der hat das an irgendeinen koreanischen Prinzen verkauft?
Oder wie war das?
Nee, Andrew Lee ist wohl Koreaner,
aber generell ein paar Startups ist wohl Unternehmer.
Und das hat erstmal dazu geführt,
dass der gesamte Moderations- und Operations-Stuff
einfach mal geschlossen zurückgetreten ist.
Die waren darüber wohl überhaupt nicht informiert.
Und seitdem versucht man sich so ein bisschen
A, zusammenzubasteln,
was da jetzt eigentlich genau passiert ist
und B, schaut so ein bisschen dabei zu, was denn da
für interessante Sachen passieren.
Was jetzt zwischendurch passiert ist,
zum Beispiel, dass sie erstmal ihre Nutzungsbedingungen
angepasst haben,
also zum Beispiel Rassismus ist jetzt erlaubt
und wenn sich Leute darüber beschweren, dann sagt man
erstmal, ja, das sieht man mal, hier die
Cancel Culture Leute sind wieder da, ne?
So, die beschweren sich darüber, dass wir
nicht mehr rassistisch reden dürfen
oder
dass wir wieder erlauben, rassistisch reden zu dürfen,
so.
Und das hat dann auch dazu geführt, dass eine ganze Menge
Open-Source-Projekte alle
erstmal sofort
umgezogen sind.
Das Zweite, was
dann passiert, ist, dass wohl alle
diese Projekte sofort,
also alle Leute von diesen Projekten
sofort gebannt wurden und die Channels
übernommen wurden von der Operations.
Das wurde nämlich dann verboten, dass man in den
Channel Topic schreibt,
wir sind jetzt übrigens bei Libera Chat.
Also alle ziehen gerade nach Libera Chat um.
Es gibt da auch eine schöne Seite, die Grafen anzeigt.
Ich kann jetzt den Link später nochmal aussuchen.
Mit User-Zahlen bei Freenode.
Die gehen alle runter.
Und entsprechend gehen die Zahlen bei Libera Chat fast 1 zu 1 hoch.
Stark.
Die Projekte ziehen jetzt also dahin um.
Dürfen das aber auf Freenode nicht kommunizieren, wie gesagt.
Ansonsten werden sie gebannt und der Channel übernommen.
Du bist jetzt ein halbes Jahr im Koma gewesen, wachst gerade auf.
Plötzlich ist da halt niemand mehr, den du kennst.
Und warum schreibt hier keiner mehr?
Und die, die schreiben, sind alles Rassisten.
Also ich habe hier noch einmal
den Blogpost gefunden, den habe ich auch in die Notes gepostet.
Von
wessen Blog
ist das jetzt?
MD.
Marco Dietrich.
As it is now known, the
Freenode IRC Network has been taken over
by a Trumpian wannabe Korean
Royalty Bitcoin Millionaire.
To make a long story short, the former
Freenode head of staff secretly
sold the network to this
person, even if it was not hers
to sell, and our lawyers have
advised us
that there is
not much that we can do about it without
some of us risking financial ruin.
Fuck you, Crystal.
Steht sich auch schön in diesem
Propost.
Ja,
genau, und seitdem geht's
bergab.
Aber vielleicht muss ja sowas passieren, um mal einen technologischen Schritt vorwärts zu machen. LiberaChat ist was? Ist das auch bloß IRC?
Das ist IRC, ja.
Achso, nevermind.
Ja, es gibt ja noch zwei weitere Eskalationen. Sie haben dann auch gleich noch IRC-Cloud gebannt. Also IRC-Cloud darf man jetzt nicht mehr verwenden, um bei Freenode zu...
Aber was haben die sich darunter vorgestellt?
Ich meine, damit
machen sie es ja wirklich bewusst kaputt.
Was denken die, wer das jetzt noch weiter benutzt?
Ja, jetzt wird es interessant.
Das wird jetzt der Parler-Ersatz
oder was?
Weiß ich nicht. Was jetzt als Letztes passiert ist,
ist, dass erstens sie gesagt haben,
so ein bisschen Branding, Freenode
ist Foss, eingeführt haben.
Und das Letzte
ist, dass sie
über eine Firma namens London Media die
Domain ISC.com gekauft haben.
und irc.com bei Freenode
betreiben. Wir verlinken auch gerne
nochmal die offizielle Ankündigung dazu.
Also wohl versuchen
hier den IRC
zu einer neuen
Blüte zu verhelfen.
Was weiß ich.
Okay, das war unerwartet,
dass diese
Motivation mit dahinter steht.
Auf dem Screenshot heißt der Binnister Prawn Salad.
Okay, irc.com
Ist eine schicke Seite, sieht gut aus.
Möchte ich fast benutzen.
Könnte man nicht denken, dass da irgendwie ein Trumpian
Wannabe-Royalty-Bitcoin-Millionär
dahintersteckt.
Ja, und das
war die Kurzzusammenfassung
von dem, was denn so passiert ist.
Und das finde ich relativ spannend.
Also, dass es das
größte IRC-Netzwerk einfach mal so
schnell innerhalb von Tagen zerlegt,
komplett, und das ist natürlich
bei aller Kritik über IRC
ein riesiges Problem, weil das natürlich
einen riesen Kulturraum vernichtet
für verschiedene Leute, die da sehr
gerne unterwegs waren
und
da entsprechend
jetzt umziehen müssen.
Und
da sind so viele Sachen schwierig dran.
Und das Erste
daran ist, wie schaffen wir es eigentlich als
Community immer wieder, solche großen
Projekte zu betreiben, die am Ende
legal einer Person gehören,
die das einfach mal so
ohne Rückfrage verkaufen kann.
So, und das ist jetzt was, was
bei sowas wie Matrix.org
nicht passieren könnte?
Soweit ich weiß, gehören die Matrix,
also die Rechte an dem Namen und die
Operations ja erstmal an der Foundation. Da gibt's dann
grundsätzlich erstmal
Board. Die kann man nicht verkaufen?
Die könnte durchaus verkaufen. Das ist auch schon passiert.
Das ist ja vor kurzem mit der
.org TLD passiert fast.
Ach stimmt, da gab's ja auch nochmal
so richtig E-Fort. Naja.
Aber da hat man wenigstens das ganze Board
davon überzeugt, dass das eine gute Idee ist.
Oh Mann.
Aber krass, Freenode war ja wirklich
so eine Instanz Jahrzehnte
hinweg. Also man hat es ja
quasi überall wirklich gehabt, dass
das darauf verwiesen wurde mit.
Und jetzt ist das einfach
nicht mehr.
Also es ist schon noch da, aber jetzt ist es
was ganz anderes.
Das reizt sich aber schön
in die Tradition der Projekte ein,
die erst Free hießen und dann Libre.
LibreNote, genau.
LibreOffice.
Oder die erst Open hießen und dann Libre.
Ja, ja.
Also, sehr schwierig.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie Libera Chat jetzt gemanagt ist,
aber es zeigt wieder das alte Problem.
Wir müssen ganz, es ist ganz wichtig an der Stelle
Infrastruktur nachzudenken und zu gucken, wem gehört eigentlich die Infrastruktur und wie können wir an der Stelle solche Sachen in Zukunft verhindern? Also an der Stelle wäre ja, man kann schon immer sagen, es kann eine Person geben, die eine Firma besitzt, aber man kann neben Abreden treffen, zum Beispiel, dass bestimmte Dinge wie ein Verkauf oder sonst was oder jegliches, was die Namensrechte und so weiter betrifft, Zustimmung von einem zweiten Gremium brauchen.
Zum Beispiel von all den Admins von Freenode.
Solche Sachen hätte man in den Vertrag gießen können.
Wurde halt nie gemacht.
Weil keiner damit rechnet, dass man es muss.
Ja.
Aber jetzt weiß man ja, dass es solche Dampbrüche gibt.
Ja, das hätte man vorher schon wissen können.
Also das ist so ein bisschen das Problem.
Im Prinzip ist dabei rausgekommen,
dass Freenode genau einer Person gehörte.
Naja, das hat am Anfang irgendein Interess losgetreten
und so ist es dann halt geblieben.
Das ist ja bei manchen anderen Infrastruktur-Pieces auch so.
Die dann aber glücklicherweise von Microsoft gekauft wurden.
Wollte Microsoft immer ein Discord kaufen?
Haben wir das nicht sogar in den Show?
Ja, die wollten vor kurzem 10 Milliarden dafür ausgeben,
aber Discord war nicht interessiert.
Ach krass, stark.
Jetzt müssen sie doch Teams weiterentwickeln
Ich würde Teams noch Gaming-Chat
mitbekommen, damit du demnächst
direkt auf deine Xbox in Teams mit deinen Freunden quatschen kannst
Ja, aber Discord
versucht ja
aus der Gaming-Schmuddelecke rauszukommen
Schmuddeleck
Ich glaube, die sehen das ein bisschen
Ich glaube, die sehen das ein bisschen so, deswegen habe ich
den Begriff verwendet, aber
Du weißt auch, warum Discord die guten Moderation-Features hat, weil sie
halt eben aus der Ecke kommen, wo es halt relevant war
von Tag 1 an und das ist
logisch. Insofern, wenn du aus
einer nicht gepamperten Friede,
Freude, Eierkuchen-Community rauskommst, dann machst
du solche Sachen halt von Anfang an.
Zu Discord muss man auch sagen,
sie haben auch einen, es ist gar nicht so schwer,
sehr direkten Zugriff zu deren
Moderationssachen zu kriegen
und die sind da überraschend komplex.
Also jetzt zum Beispiel zu Pride Month weiß ich,
dass das Moderationsteam die Möglichkeit
gegeben hat, dass man, wenn man einen Server
betreibt, der sich um Queer-Themen
und ähnliches kümmert und so weiter und so fort,
dass man dem Moderationsteam
von Discord schreiben konnte und sagen,
hey, im Übrigen, ich würde gerne meinen Server flaggen,
dass ich da unter Umständen ein Target bin.
Und dann hat man
bei denen
eine entsprechende Fastlane
bekommen. Krass, nicht schlecht.
Also die sind da,
es ist ja auch wieder eine soziale Lösung.
Die schauen sich ihre Plattform an und sagen, was wird
diesen Monat heiß? Aufpassen, hier
Zeitmonth und
genau, so
solche Sachen sind ja,
am Ende finde ich das Lustige an
Chatthemen, dass sie halt soziale Dynamiken
so schön abbilden und eben halt nicht nur Technik
sind.
Und da sieht man ja auch,
wie sehr Fienot da so ein bisschen die soziale
Dynamik abbildet, dass wir gerne über
Technik reden, aber ungern über die
Rechte an der Stelle
und ich
habe seit Jahren
ist mein Argument an der Stelle immer,
man muss sich da sehr drum kümmern,
weil ansonsten ist das einfach ein
Angriffsvektor und das sieht man genau an dieser Stelle.
Diese Person ist hingegangen, hat gesagt,
hey, also ich kann mir gut
vorstellen, wie das gelaufen ist.
Euer Netzwerk kann noch so sicher sein, aber ich kann eure
Firma kaufen.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass wahrscheinlich
der Deal zwischen diesen beiden
Personen war, hey, du betreibst hier irgendwie
seit 15 Jahren irgendwie Freeloads,
kommt irgendwie nichts bei rum, das
wird irgendwie dann auch irgendwann frustrierend und so weiter
und es geht irgendwie nirgendwo hin und
IRC3
dauert noch eine ganze
Weile und so weiter und so fort und das ist
also solche offenen Communities zu managen
ist ja auch zu großen Teilen einfach auch ein bisschen Frust
und wenn man da mal
einknickt und dann jemand
um die Ecke kommt und sagt, du
würdest du einfach Geld dafür nehmen? Ich könnte
dir den Namen abkaufen und
sonst was und offensichtlich waren die ja eh schon im
Gespräch, weil dieser
Andrew Lee ja wohl schon über lange Zeit an dieser Firma irgendwie transitiv, also offensichtlich gab es Beteiligungen an dieser Firma, stand in einem der Artikel drin, einfach gesagt hat, du, ich nehme es dir ab, ne?
Ja.
Ich gebe dir Geld und nehme es dir ab.
Und eventuell sitzt diese Person jetzt auch da und denkt sich, ach fuck, aber so wurde ja nicht geredet.
Ich habe auch schon mit mehreren Leuten geredet, die kleine Firmen hatten,
Fossfirmen oder kleinen bis mittelgroßen und sonst was,
und dann irgendwann an Investor verkauft haben
und in den Vertrag eben nicht verschiedene Sachen reingeschrieben haben,
die unbedingt zu machen sind.
Und der Investor dann kurz nach Vertragsunterschrift gesagt hat,
cool, die Sachen, die nicht im Vertrag stehen,
die vergessen wir nach einem Jahr.
Also es ist jetzt überraschend, dass das so schnell geht.
Aber das sind die gleichen Sachen, die auch bei,
bei Übernahme von irgendwelchen Open-Source-Libraries
oder Tools passieren können,
wenn jemand keinen Bock mehr auf Maintenance hat.
Wir hatten solche Geschichten ja auch schon.
Ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf Maintenance von dieser Lib,
die habe auch irgendwie leider 100.000 Leute am Tag runterladen.
Wer da hat zweimal contributiert,
den kenne ich schon, dem gebe ich das einfach
und zack, war ein Crypto-Miner drin.
Oder irgendwer wirft halt wirklich Geld drauf
und du kriegst halt nicht mit,
dass das bekannte Library gekauft wurde von irgendwas.
Das ist halt einfach nur eine Dependency in deiner Riste, aber
genau.
Naja.
Das sind alles Vektoren,
die nicht nur theoretisch
da sind, sondern ich denke, was das
sehr stark zeigt, ist, die werden auch aktiv genutzt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Auf kurz oder lang halt einfach.
Hier hat es jetzt halt lang gedauert.
An anderen
Stellen ist es halt kürzer.
Und
das ist ein
großes Problem, das ich bei uns
in Force-Communities sehe,
ist, dass wir
wenig Leute haben, die solche Sachen mit
dem
manchmal auch dem entsprechend angemessenen Zynismus
betrachten.
Was weiß ich.
Man kommt schnell in diesen Modus rein, dass man
einfach so von der Technik,
nur als sich auf die Technik konzentriert,
davon irgendwie begeistert ist und
sieht, dass es funktioniert und dann ist man in so einem
bisschen blauäugigen Modus,
kann ich mir vorstellen. Deswegen ist ja das
die ersten 20 Jahre so unsicher gewesen,
weil die Leute halt nur an das Positive Menschen gedacht
haben und nicht an den Missbrauch, der stattfinden kann.
Ein Wunder, dass
Nestle noch nicht in Technik eingestiegen ist.
Oh Gott.
Nestle
kauft jetzt Libera Chat
oder sowas.
Ja, Leute, also letztes
Mal hatten wir EA
kauft System D, jetzt sind wir bei
Nestle kauft Libera Chat, also
das kann durchaus
passieren.
Wir müssen uns für die nächste Runde
wir machen mal
einen Sonderpodcast.
Klassische Firmen kaufen Open-Source-Projekte
und was dabei rauskommt.
Oh ja, da gibt es bestimmt ein paar schöne Beispiele.
Das wird unsere Nostradamus-Folge und dann
in der Zukunft berufen wir uns
drauf, bald wirklich irgendwie diese
Konsequenzen. Ich glaube, dafür kann man einen schönen
Generator schreiben.
Dann machst du dann so
Nesquik
Oh, der ist schon wieder Nesle.
Nespresso, ne ist auch Nestle.
Jetzt bin ich in diesem
Nest-Modus gerade.
Vorwerk kauft
Node.js oder und sowas.
Ich sehe,
ich brauche auch nicht.
Ich habe vor kurzem
die Open Source
Evil Technos
Title Generator.
Ich habe vor kurzem Vorwerk bei irgendeiner
größeren Open Source Sache gesehen.
Oh nein.
It's happening. You heard it here first.
Aber dann lass uns doch mal vielleicht den Bogen schlagen.
Wir haben jetzt eine ganze Menge wieder Chatprotokolle und Hersteller und Ansätze aufgezählt.
Was ist denn das, wo ihr euch momentan am wohlsten fühlt?
Das haben wir ja relativ klar gesagt, schon während wir durchgegangen sind, oder?
Die Sachen, die ihr jetzt für eure Projekte bereits ausgewählt habt oder für die ihr mitunter sogar arbeitet, sind also die, wo ihr euch auch am wohlsten fühlt.
Matrix ist für mich so das eine, was halt wirklich alle Checkboxen abhackt.
Es ist zwar stellenweise noch ein bisschen schwierig zu bedienen
und ich kann es leider noch nicht da ausempfehlen, darauf zuzugreifen,
weil halt die Kleinfrage immer noch immer so ein bisschen ungeklärt ist,
beziehungsweise LLM ist halt bedingt nur schick und bedienbar,
aber es ist halt das einzige Protokoll, das einzige System,
was wirklich alles erfüllt, was ich gerne haben möchte.
Und deswegen ist es für mich halt das.
und wenn ich halt aktuell noch damit leben muss,
dass ich halt Matrix über Bridges
zu WhatsApp,
zu Telegram, zu iMessage
selbst mit anspreche,
was die iMessage
ist auch so ein spannendes Ding,
aber dann ist
es für mich halt okay so. Es ist
nicht schön, aber ich lebe gerne
in der Matrix-Welt und bin da sehr glücklich mit.
Habt ihr euch zufällig diese
XMPP vs. Matrix-Wigiseite angeguckt,
die ich in die Show-Notes geschmissen hatte?
Vor einer Weile mal. Ich glaube, da haben wir schon mal
drauf gewesen.
Haltet ihr das für einen validen
Vergleich? Ich meine, hier sind,
das ist jetzt sehr, die Quintessenz ist
quasi
gefühlt, warum zum Geier macht ihr Matrix
konzentriert sich lieber auf XMPP?
Ich weiß nicht,
die Punkte, die hier aufgeführt
sind, wie Total Active Users
sind besser bei XMPP, weil das sind 2 Milliarden
und bei Matrix wissen wir es einfach nicht,
das ist ja kein Vergleich.
Oder auch diese Gegenüberstellung,
bei XMPP gibt es halt ein offenes
Extensible Protocol.
Das ist halt bei Matrix irgendwie
nicht so, weil es eher in den Client Libraries drinsteckt.
Kann ich
nicht viel zu sagen. Also ich
gebe das mal zur, ich gebe dieses
links und rechts hier mal
zu Protokoll.
Kann mich allerdings jetzt nicht wirklich
gut darauf
ich kann jetzt das nicht
wirklich gut vortragen, was hier drinsteht.
Ja, hier gerade so hier, Usage in Big Networks.
XMPP sind usage bei Google, nicht mehr.
WhatsApp, ja schön, dass das eJabber-D
drunter ist, aber das hilft uns halt nicht, weil es ein geschlossenes
System ist. Zählt hier Live-Journal
auf, ganz im Ernst. Das ist halt einfach nicht mehr aktuell.
Und hier, dass die Bundespolizei Deutschland
XMPP nutzt, aha.
Spannend.
Gut, okay, also wir gehen jetzt mal zum Bruder.
Mir hilft auch nicht, dass die Bundeswehr Matrix nutzt, aber
das ist... Weißt du, dass du deinen
lokalen Stabsführer über Matrix
anschreiben könntest? Nee, ich wette nicht, dass das federated,
deren komischer Messenger... Meinst du nicht?
Ich wollte ja, das war so ein geplantes
Neo-Feature, was ich für meinen Matrix-Client,
was ich nie irgendwo öffentlich dokumentiert habe
bisher, aber das wollte ich irgendwann mal einbauen,
einfach so hinterrückst, so als Easter Egg.
Wenn du Neo nutzen willst, um dich bei
Bundeswehr-Server anzumelden, dann kriegst du einfach einen
kleinen ganz in, keine Ahnung,
brauner Text auf braunem Hintergrund oder ein fetten
Stinkefinger-Emoji oder nö.
Vielleicht.
Das ist nicht braun auf braun,
das ist Camouflage.
Ja, genau.
Das ist Taunfarbe.
Ja, ich finde,
Ich verwende
Matrix eigentlich nur als, wie gesagt,
als
Standardplattform für unsere Konferenzen aus den Gründen,
die ich mit habe und um
zu LiberaChat zu federaten. Das sollte
man noch sagen. LiberaChat hat, wie gesagt, jetzt
eine offiziell supportete Matrix-Bridge.
Die haben zusammengearbeitet. Das heißt,
dass es dokumentiert
und so macht uns. Oh gut, Freenode hatte das vorher ja auch.
Da hatte Matrix.org direkt die Freenode-Bridge gehostet.
Ja, aber
ich glaube, da war es mehr so
Das machen wir einfach.
Wir machen das mal und wir testen das.
Aber
da ist es auf jeden Fall von beiden
Seiten promotet worden, habe ich an der Stelle festgestellt.
Ansonsten muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich
bin extrem starker Discord-Nutzer geworden.
Aus verschiedenen Gründen.
Also jetzt mal Firmenchat
beiseite, aber privat
verwende ich extrem
stark Discord.
Discord ist halt auch so ein Community-Ding.
Also man kann natürlich auch DMs auf Discord schreiben.
Man kann Freundelisten führen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie exzessiv du das nutzt. Ich nutze das Feature quasi gar nicht.
Also es gibt genau eine Person, mit der ich eine Discord-DM führe,
obwohl ich gar nicht weiß, wie so eigentlich.
Discord nutze ich für, das war früher mal diese deutsche Swift-Community,
die wir auf Slack früher hatten und irgendwann der Meinung war,
es ist einfach scheiße, dass die History immer wieder verschwindet.
Das war so das Hauptproblem. Natürlich gab es noch andere Probleme.
Lass zu Discord gehen.
Wir hatten nie wirklich viele Gründe, die Moderation-Features zu nutzen, Gott sei Dank.
Das war kurz vor Schluss tatsächlich mal kurz ein bisschen kritisch geworden.
Aber ansonsten hatten wir einfach eine sehr angenehme, tolle Community.
Die haben wir dann wegen der History vor allem auf Discord migriert.
Und seitdem nutze ich Discord auch täglich mit dieser Community,
aber auch nicht darüber hinaus.
Was mir beim Discord noch positiv auffällt,
sind Features, über die wir jetzt noch gar nicht geredet haben,
sowas wie offene Voice Chats.
Voice Räume.
Voice Räume, was ja jetzt sowas wie Clubhouse ganz groß macht.
Oh, wie ist dein Podcast? Wir reden jetzt über Clubhouse.
Ich glaube, er ist doch wieder tot.
Ich bin wieder gestorben.
Meinst du?
Philipp Amthor war doch online schon vor unserer vorletzten Folge.
Dann muss es tot sein.
Das ist aber eigentlich ein ganz cooles Feature,
was ich gerade so für
tatsächlich für Podcasting-Communities
ganz spannend finde.
Und da ist es halt schade, wenn man das in so einem
Roadgarten stattfinden lässt.
Warum ist das für Podcast-Communities interessant?
Du kannst einen Live-Raum machen
in einem moderierten Voice-Channel, wo du
die vier Leute reden kannst, beziehungsweise du kannst
Rederechte verteilen live?
Wir könnten jetzt quasi ein offenes
Panel aus dieser Folge machen zum Beispiel.
Was allerdings
vielleicht nicht unbedingt dann die Hörqualität
im Nachhinein erhöht, weiß ich
nicht. Aber das macht ja
der Pridlov ganz
viel. Man könnte es ja einfach als
Livestream-Option quasi bieten.
Wir nehmen quasi wir auf in dem
Voice-Raum und niemand anders hat
Voice-Rechte. Aber dann brauchst du es nicht machen.
Es geht quasi darum, dass du irgendwie
gerade jetzt bei dem, was wir gerade besprochen haben,
dass da irgendjemand, der sich besser auskennt, dann plötzlich
sagt, warte mal, warte mal,
ich hab da was zu zu sagen. Das fand ich
eigentlich ganz cool so als Projekt. Das klingt ganz witzig.
Was ist eigentlich, weil du das
hier in deiner Liste bei coolen Themen hast,
Matrix als Basis von Wasabi?
Was ist denn Wasabi?
Wasabi ist
das Framework,
also wenn ihr auf dem Rust-Fest
wart, auf dem Rust-Fest
Global, das Video-Framework,
dass sich auch noch zusätzliche Plugins
einbinden lassen und so weiter und so fort.
Das heißt Wasabi.
Es existiert
und es soll seit Ewigkeiten Open Source werden.
Deswegen habe ich es gefunden.
Nice.
Und das passiert auf Matrix?
Es gibt ein Matrix-Plugin.
Wenn dann ein Talk läuft,
gibt es dann einen entsprechenden Channel dazu.
Und der Channel wird dann entsprechend eingebunden.
Eine sehr coole Sache, die Wasabi anbietet,
ist, dass es im Prinzip Instant Replay hat.
Also wenn der Talk vorbei ist,
kannst du dir sofort das Recording anschauen.
Das ist cool.
Das Recording-Stream.
Also es ist nicht einfach nur ein langer Videostream,
sondern es weiß, jetzt fängt ein Stream an und so weiter und so fort.
Es funktioniert über ein paar eigentlich gar nicht so schwere technische Tricks.
Im Hintergrund kann momentan kein kommerzielles Produkt
und wir würden das ganz gerne
bei Gelegenheit dann auch Open Source
anbieten.
Das klingt ziemlich geil, dann
freuen wir uns auf den Link dazu,
wenn das irgendwann
Open Source ist.
Cool, wir haben jetzt
ziemlich lange geredet. Ich habe
sich zwar einzelne Hörer für unsere 50. Folge
einen 8-Stunden-Podcast gewünscht,
aber
vielleicht können wir so langsam den Bogen
spannen
und zu einem
zu einem Abschluss kommen. Also momentan,
deswegen habe ich diese Frage gerade eben schon gestellt,
zeichnet sich ab, ach Matrix geht
eigentlich, können wir jetzt erstmal eine Weile im Auge
behalten und
vielleicht löst es ja noch ein paar von den
offenen Problemen mit der Zeit.
Dafür ist Kylian jetzt ja zuständig.
Genau.
Ja, also für die
Leute, denen der Kontext fehlt,
ich habe es in der letzten Folge
mal angesprochen, ich arbeite
jetzt bei einem Matrix-Startup, wo wir
einen Matrix-Client auch bauen, der
der Bridges mit eingebaut hat.
Und es ist genau dafür da, dass man
das mit ein bisschen bootstrapt,
das Ökosystem. Und auch wenn du
gar nicht mehr wissen musst, dass da Matrix drunter liegt,
dass dann potenziell
mehr und mehr Leute schon
auf Matrix mit ansprechbar sind.
Sehr cool.
Habt ihr
Picks
für diese
Folge? Ich würde unseren Gast
mal vorlassen.
Ja, ich habe Picks. Ich habe diesmal nur Personen,
als Picks oder
deren
Businesses. Ich habe
Anfang
Juli aufnehmen,
Pubstruck.com, das ist Ashley Williams,
Teil des First Core Teams,
hat sich selbstständig gemacht,
macht Beratung zu Open-Source-Strukturen
und wie man genau solche Sachen verhindert,
dass einem Freenote unter
dem Hintern weggekauft wird.
Das ist eine schöne Marktlücke.
Kann ich sehr empfehlen, auch
wunderbare
Wunderbarer Firmenname, Pubstruct ist sowohl RAS-Syntax als auch Public Structure.
Sehr clever.
Die zweite Person, die ich pitchen möchte, ist Marabos.
Marabos hat eine Firma namens Fusion Engineering.
Fusion Engineering bauen einen Drohnen-Controller-Stock.
Aber ansonsten kennen sie sich extrem gut mit Sensoren und Control Theory aus, wie man so schön sagt.
Also alles, was Hardware hat, die die Umwelt misst und dabei eine Drohne nicht zum Ausstützen bringt, ist genau deren Ding.
und das Ganze auf Embedded Linux
kommen aus dem
Rust-Bereich. Mara leitet auch das
Library-Team im Rust-Projekt, deswegen so
Mara ist immer die Person, die die
schönen Beispiele für die neuen Library
Features auf Twitter mit Code-Beispielen
darstellt, oder?
Ja,
oder halt auch in den tiefsten Horror
von was kann man mit dem Rust-Compiler machen.
Oh ja, ich hab natürlich erst gelesen,
oh Gott, das geht ja doch.
Die Mischung aus
Lovecraft und Rust-C kriegt Mara
schon ganz gut hin. Und die dritte Person ist mein Standard-Pitch
eigentlich Sam Aaron. Sam Aaron macht Sonic Pi. Warum pitte ich
Sam Aaron immer? Sonic Pi ist das Framework, das ganz, ganz, oder was heißt
das Tool, das ganz, ganz viele Musiker verwenden, die auf dem Rustfest immer spielen
und Musikerinnen. Und er macht das,
baut das komplett selbst und man kann ihn auf Patreon unterstützen. Also
macht davon seinen Lebensunterhalt. Und man kann
ihn auf Konferenzen mieten, dass er dort Musik
macht.
Das kann man alternativ, wenn
einem die Patron, also
wenn einem die
Patron-Belohnungen nicht
groß genug sind, kann man ihn auch einfach da reinladen.
Ja.
Sehr cool, vielen lieben Dank dafür.
Ich glaube, an der Stelle können wir
jetzt auch sagen, das war
eine ziemlich gute, lange Folge.
Auf jeden Fall.
Vielen Dank, Florian, dass du uns mal wieder besucht hast.
Kannst du jederzeit gerne wiederkommen.
Ist immer ein Vergnügen.
Nicht erst in drei Jahren wieder.
Genau, und damit
möchte ich mich auch ehrlich gesagt bedanken
bei allen unseren Zuhörern, die bei dieser
langen Folge so lange durchgehalten haben.
Ja, und bei den 49, nee, 50 Folgen davor
sogar schon. Also das ist ja an sich die
51. Aufnahme. Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass wir mal 50 Folgen akronomisierbar schaffen.
Nee, niemals. Aber wir machen es noch ein bisschen weiter, oder?
Ja, ich auch.
Gut, wir sind auch in letzter Zeit wieder mal ein bisschen langsamer geworden,
aber ich würde das einfach mal auf die Tatsache schieben,
dass gerade Sommer ist und
wir auch alle auf Arbeit so ein bisschen viel zu tun haben.
Also macht euch keine Sorge,
wenn es auch manchmal anderthalb Monate dauert,
bis die nächste Akronomisierung erfolgt.
Wir haben auch schon die nächste im Petto.
Die sind manchmal ein bisschen langsam
zu organisieren,
weil Leute auch, ja, momentan ist einfach auch Sommerloch
und Leute sind nicht da.
Aber wir machen definitiv weiter.
Also vielen Dank, Florian,
dass du mit dabei warst.
Wir freuen uns jederzeit wieder auf dich.
Und du darfst den Countdown
für die Abmoderation machen.
Weißt du, wovon ich rede?
Ja.
Die nächste Folge startet in
3, 2, 1.